Hello and welcome to your second drink of stress relief, part one.
This episode has the famous fire drill cold open.
We got so many wonderful tidbits from our crew on how that all went down.
And you know what?
I'm really proud of how we broke down this episode.
Lady, it's one of my favorite podcast moments that we did because we really dug into it.
We got so much good stuff.
We got a message from Arena S in Russia who wrote us about.
你好，欢迎收听你的第二杯压力缓解（Stress Relief）播客，第一部分。这一集有著名的火灾演习开场。我们从剧组那里得到了很多关于拍摄过程的精彩花絮。你知道吗？我真的很为我们拆解这一集的方式感到自豪。Lady，这是我们做过的我最喜欢的播客时刻之一，因为我们真的深入挖掘了它。我们得到了很多好东西。我们收到了一封来自俄罗斯Arena S的来信，她写信给我们谈到了……
the fire drill scene. Arena said, this is one of my favorite episodes ever, naturally, because of the
funniest ever cold open. When I watched it the first time, I couldn't stop laughing. I think I even
teared up. That's how funny I found it. Now, here is the amazing thing. Arena went on to say,
I work as an English tutor, and whenever I feel like my students need cheering up or we need to
lighten the mood, I ask them, have you seen the office? And most of them say they haven't.
And so I say, I'm going to show you a little clip, just watch.
And I turn on this cold open and they just lose it.
It's my favorite thing ever.
火灾演习的那一幕。Arena说，这是我最喜欢的一集，当然是因为那段史上最搞笑的开场。我第一次看的时候，笑得停不下来。我想我甚至都笑出眼泪了。我觉得它太搞笑了。现在，神奇的事情来了。Arena接着说，我是一名英语老师，每当我觉得学生们需要振作起来，或者我们需要调节气氛时，我就会问他们：“你看过《办公室》（The Office）吗？”大多数人都说没看过。于是我说：“我要给你们看一个小片段，看着。”然后我打开这个开场，他们就彻底笑疯了。这是我最喜欢的事情。
I see how they light up watching something with authentic language and it's just hilarious.
I keep count of how many people began watching the show after my lessons and so far it's about five.
So my point is, besides being one of the most iconic series ever, your show opens the window into the American culture.
and fantastic English language for many students who are learning it.
Thank you so much.
Oh, that is so fun.
It's very funny to me thinking that this cold open is like an introduction to American culture.
Oh, no.
我看着他们观看这种地道语言片段时眼睛发亮的样子，真是太搞笑了。我统计过有多少人在我的课后开始看这部剧，到目前为止大约有五个人。所以我的意思是，除了作为史上最具标志性的剧集之一，你们的节目还为许多正在学习英语的学生打开了一扇了解美国文化的窗口，而且英语非常棒。非常感谢。哦，那太有趣了。想到这个开场被当作了解美国文化的入门，我觉得很有意思。哦，不。
Actually, any, like, clip of the office.
Exactly.
Well, this episode also has the super cringe CPR training session,
which we've also heard is used as a teaching tool.
Mike R from Portland, Oregon said, it was my birthday and a small group of friends got together to celebrate at a local restaurant.
Everyone had recently experienced some setback or bad luck, myself included.
One guest had just lost her job.
Another guest found out her first round of IVF treatment didn't take.
其实，任何《办公室》的片段都可以。没错。好吧，这一集还有那个超级尴尬的CPR急救培训环节，我们也听说它被用作教学工具。来自俄勒冈州波特兰的Mike R说，那天是我的生日，一小群朋友聚在当地一家餐馆庆祝。每个人最近都经历了一些挫折或倒霉事，包括我自己。一位客人刚丢了工作。另一位客人发现她第一轮试管婴儿治疗失败了。
A couple of people shared that one of their kids was having some serious issues, and I was having my own medical issue at the time.
As we sat sulking at my sad birthday, a man at another table, unrelated to our group, was showing signs of choking.
Luckily for him, one of my friends is a doctor.
My friend sprang into action and performed the Heimlich maneuver.
After what seemed like an eternity, a piece of steak was dislodged from the man's throat.
My friend was exhausted mentally and physically after his heroic deed.
The incident was scary and I felt helpless.
realizing that no one else was trained to help that man, I organized a CPR day at my office
几个人分享说他们的孩子正面临一些严重的问题，而我当时也有自己的医疗问题。当我们坐在我那悲伤的生日聚会上生闷气时，另一桌一个与我们无关的男人出现了窒息的迹象。幸运的是，我的一个朋友是医生。我的朋友立即采取行动，进行了海姆立克急救法。在经历了漫长的等待后，一块牛排从那个人的喉咙里被排了出来。在完成这一英雄壮举后，我的朋友在精神和身体上都精疲力竭。那次事件很可怕，我感到很无助。意识到没有其他人受过帮助那个人的训练，我在我的办公室组织了一次CPR日。
where many office references were made. Our trainer commented that the office is referenced in
nearly every workshop she facilitates. Score one for the guy who lived and score one for the office
for making the world a safer place. Well, in our breakdown lady, we talked a lot about
how people who have seen this episode have gone on to like save lives because of the stay in alive tip
that the instructor gives.
The song.
Ah,
a,
在那里，大家提到了很多《办公室》的梗。我们的培训师评论说，她主持的几乎每场研讨会都会提到《办公室》。为那个活下来的人记上一分，也为《办公室》让世界变得更安全记上一分。嗯，在我们的拆解中，Lady，我们谈了很多关于看过这一集的人如何因为教练给出的《Stayin' Alive》小贴士而拯救生命的故事。那首歌。啊，啊，
Stay in alive.
Exactly.
And speaking of the CPR instructor,
we got a letter from Robin Lynch who plays Rose.
In our breakdown, we said,
hey, Robin, we're trying to get a hold of you.
Hit us up, and she did.
Stayin' alive, stayin' alive。没错。说到CPR教练，我们收到了一封来自饰演Rose的Robin Lynch的信。在我们的拆解中，我们说：“嘿，Robin，我们想联系你。联系我们吧。”她真的联系了。
Here's what her letter said.
Hi, I just listened to your podcast about stress relief.
Thank you so much for your kind words.
I'd love to answer any questions and talk about our day on set.
It was such an amazing experience.
And, lady, I was digging around, and there are like four minutes of extra footage from
those CPR scenes in the super fan episodes.
So it got us thinking.
她的信是这样写的：嗨，我刚听了你们关于《压力缓解》的播客。非常感谢你们的溢美之词。我很乐意回答任何问题，并谈谈我们在片场的日子。那真是一次奇妙的经历。而且，Lady，我翻找了一下，在超级粉丝版（Superfan episodes）里，那些CPR场景还有四分钟的额外镜头。这让我们想到……
Actually, Angie got you thinking.
Yeah, I said we should do an Office Lady 6.0 where we talk with Robin and we can unpack some of the extra scenes and just hear all about her time on set.
I said, I love it. So that's what we're going to do. We've reached out to Robin and we can't wait to share more in an upcoming Office Lady 6.0.
And now here's your second drink of Stress Relief, Part 1.
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together.
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast.
just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everyone.
其实是Angie让你想到的。是的，我说我们应该做一个《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）6.0版本，和Robin聊聊，我们可以拆解一些额外场景，听听她在片场的故事。我说，我喜欢这个主意。所以这就是我们要做的。我们已经联系了Robin，迫不及待想在即将到来的《办公室女士》6.0中分享更多内容。现在，这是你的第二杯《压力缓解》第一部分。我是Jenna Fischer。我是Angela Kinsey。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做终极《办公室》重温播客，专为你准备。每周，我们都会拆解《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。
Good morning, you guys. It's early here today for us. It's early here, and we have a lot to cover.
So much. We came in early. We have so much to say today, but I have to point out an observation
before we get started. Is it all my snacks and beverages on my side? You actually do have a ton of snacks and
beverages. You have a hot tea, a cold tea, a water, a granola bar, a banana, and some naughty oats cereal.
I do. It's a lot. You knew this was going to be a big episode. I came ready. Clearly. I came ready. You've
an entire picnic. I will always show up with iced tea and snacks. Just know that. That's me rolling in to any
event. My observation was actually going to be about your document. Oh. It's so charming. It is
printed words. It's not no cards. It is a pile of paper. But what you have done is you have
大家早上好。今天对我们来说很早。这里很早，我们要讲的内容很多。太多了。我们来得很早。今天我们要说的话很多，但在开始之前，我必须指出一个观察结果。你那边所有的零食和饮料都是我的吗？你确实有一大堆零食和饮料。你有热茶、冷茶、水、燕麦棒、香蕉和一些“淘气燕麦”麦片。确实。太多了。你知道这一集会很长。我准备好了。显然。我准备好了。你简直带了一整个野餐。我总是会带着冰茶和零食出现。记住这一点。这就是我参加任何活动的风格。我的观察其实是关于你的文档。哦。它太迷人了。它是打印出来的文字。不是卡片。它是一堆纸。但你做的是……
taken like regular lined, what's that paper called? It's called notebook paper out of a spiral binder
because clearly I ran out of printer paper. Is that what happened? That's what happened. That's why
your pages are on lined notebook. It's printed though. Yes. Did you think that I just wanted to print
on notebook paper.
Lady, I didn't know what you were doing.
And I have a Post-it note.
I just found it interesting when we sat down.
No, this is me, you know, last night as I print my document out, you might have heard a few
拿了那种带横线的，那叫什么纸？它叫螺旋装订本里的笔记本纸，因为显然我的打印纸用完了。是这样吗？就是这样。这就是为什么你的页面是横线笔记本纸。不过是打印出来的。是的。你以为我只是想在笔记本纸上打印吗？Lady，我不知道你在做什么。而且我还有一张便利贴。当我们坐下来时，我只是觉得这很有趣。不，这是我，你知道，昨晚打印文档时，你可能听到了一些……
expletives because we were out of printer paper.
So then I was like, damn it, it's 9 o'clock at night.
A good hack.
There you go.
Hack.
Go into your kids' room, get their notebook, rip out the pages.
Your printer will print on it.
I feel like we might have helped some people today.
脏话，因为我们的打印纸用完了。所以我当时想，该死，现在是晚上9点。一个好招。给你。妙招。去你孩子的房间，拿他们的笔记本，撕下几页。你的打印机可以在上面打印。我觉得我们今天可能帮到了一些人。
We might have.
All right, well, let's talk about why we're here today. It is Stress Relief Part 1, Season 5, Episode 14, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Jeff Blitz.
Exactly. You might be thinking, ladies, it's stress relief. That isn't that big, except it had the cold open to end all cold opens.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. We'll be breaking that down. Oh, yeah, we will. It's going to take a while.
This episode originally aired as an hour-long episode.
We're going to have to break it down in two parts.
So today we're covering the first half of stress relief.
Would you like a summary?
我们可能帮到了。好吧，让我们谈谈我们今天为什么在这里。这是《压力缓解》第一部分，第五季第14集，由Paul Lieberstein编剧，Jeff Blitz导演。没错。你可能在想，女士们，这只是《压力缓解》，没什么大不了的，除了它有那个终极开场。哦，是的。哦，是的。我们会拆解那个开场。哦，是的，我们会。这会花点时间。这一集最初作为一小时长的剧集播出。我们必须把它拆成两部分。所以今天我们讲《压力缓解》的前半部分。你想要一个总结吗？
I really would.
All right.
It starts with that cold open you were talking about, Angela.
Dwight takes matters into his own hands when his coworkers failed to pay attention to his fire safety seminar.
He used PowerPoint.
Big mistake.
He's going to give us a practical fire drill.
on. How will we react on our feet? That's right. Well, Stanley has a heart attack. It doesn't end well.
我真的很想要。好的。它从你刚才提到的那个开场开始，Angela。当同事们不注意他的消防安全研讨会时，Dwight采取了行动。他用了PPT。大错特错。他要给我们来一场实战火灾演习。看看我们会有什么即时反应。没错。好吧，Stanley心脏病发作了。结局不太好。
It doesn't. And that lands Dwight in hot water with corporate. I mean, he almost burned the building.
Stanley had a heart attack. Dwight, how do you have a job? Michael hires a CPR expert to teach the office what we
should do if Stanley has another heart attack, but Dwight has his own ideas of how to use the CPR dummy.
Hello, Clarice.
Oh, dear.
Finally, we learned that Pam's mom and dad are having a rough patch in their marriage
and that Pam's dad has actually been bunking with Jim and Pam.
Sans robe.
确实。这让Dwight在公司那里陷入了困境。我是说，他差点烧了整栋楼。Stanley心脏病发作了。Dwight，你怎么还能保住工作？Michael雇了一位CPR专家来教办公室如果Stanley再次心脏病发作该怎么办，但Dwight对如何使用CPR假人有自己的想法。你好，Clarice。哦，天哪。最后，我们了解到Pam的父母婚姻出现了裂痕，Pam的爸爸一直住在Jim和Pam家。没穿睡袍。
Yeah.
Was he walking around in his tiny whitties?
I don't know, but she needs to get him a robe.
Aw.
Fast fact number one, this episode aired after the Super Bowl on Sunday, February 1st, 2009.
I mean, if I had an air horn thing, I'd fire it off.
Because this was huge for us.
Sophia C wrote in to say, Jenna, I have a fast fact for you.
是啊。他是不是穿着小内裤走来走去？我不知道，但她得给他买件睡袍。噢。速记事实第一条，这一集是在2009年2月1日星期日的超级碗之后播出的。我是说，如果我有一个气喇叭，我肯定会按响它。因为这对我们来说太重要了。Sophia C写信来说，Jenna，我有一个速记事实给你。
Sophia.
This was the most watched episode of the entire office series.
What?
Yeah.
And she's right.
I looked it up.
Angela, do you want to know how many people?
Oh, my gosh.
Sophia。这是《办公室》全系列中收视率最高的一集。什么？是的。她是正确的。我查过了。Angela，你想知道有多少人看吗？天哪。
I'm horrible at guessing.
Like, you know, guess the jelly bean in the jar.
I'm so off.
I know.
Yeah, I can't do that either.
Okay, I'm going to guess 10 million people.
That seems like a big number.
That is a big number.
我猜数字最差劲了。就像，你知道，猜罐子里的软糖。我总是差很远。我知道。是的，我也做不到。好吧，我猜1000万人。这看起来是个很大的数字。确实是个大数字。
But it was 22.9 million people.
Holy smokes.
Yeah.
So it is definitely the most watched episode of the office.
And it's also the only episode of the office to ever reach over 20 million viewers.
Wow.
But now I have another question for you.
I don't know.
但那是2290万人。天哪。是的，所以它绝对是《办公室》收视率最高的一集。它也是《办公室》唯一一集观众人数超过2000万的剧集。哇。但现在我还有另一个问题要问你。我不知道。
Is it more guessing number stuff?
It's more guessing.
It's not numbers, though.
Oh, good.
Well, I have a shot.
Can you guess what our second most watched episode was?
Oh, no.
Of the whole series?
还是猜数字吗？还是猜，但不是数字。哦，太好了。好吧，我试试。你能猜出我们收视率第二高的是哪一集吗？哦，不。全系列？
Of the whole series.
This was number one.
What do you think number two was?
The finale?
The pilot.
What?
Really?
全系列。这是第一名。你觉得第二名是什么？大结局？试播集。什么？试播集。真的吗？
It had 11.2 million viewers.
The pilot that I wore my own clothes in.
Yeah.
From Target.
Mm-hmm.
Wow.
11.2 million people saw your outfit.
Well, you're welcome, America.
它有1120万观众。那个我穿着自己衣服的试播集。是的。从Target买的。嗯哼。哇。1120万人看到了你的装扮。好吧，不客气，美国。
Interestingly enough, airing after the Super Bowl did not seem to get us a bump in viewership going forward.
Oh, it was like a one and done?
Kind of.
So the episode that aired before the Super Bowl was Prince Family Paper.
Okay.
And we had 8.7 million viewers.
That was kind of our averagey range.
有趣的是，在超级碗之后播出似乎并没有让我们的收视率在后续有所提升。哦，就像是一次性的？算是吧。所以超级碗之前播出的那一集是《王子家庭纸业》（Prince Family Paper）。好的。我们有870万观众。好的。那算是我们的平均范围。
Right.
After the Super Bowl is lecture circuit, and we actually had a drop in the ratings to 8.4.
Oh.
So some regular viewers.
I don't know.
They were like, not after that Super Bowl stunt.
Fast fact number two, Randy told me that there were rumors that we were going to get that 2009 Super Bowl slot from as early as the end of season four.
Geez. They planned that that far out? I guess so. There had been some talk that maybe it would go to the apprentice. The apprentice was going to get the slot. But our executive producers really fought for the office to get it. And we did. Randy said it was part of our internal shooting records as of May 2008, which was well before we had ever started shooting season five. So we'd known for a while this was coming.
没错。超级碗之后是《讲座巡回》（Lecture Circuit），我们的收视率实际上降到了840万。哦。所以一些常规观众。我不知道。他们可能觉得，超级碗那次特技之后就不看了。速记事实第二条，Randy告诉我，早在第四季末就有传言说我们要获得2009年超级碗的档期。天哪。他们计划得那么早？我想是吧。曾有一些讨论说可能会给《学徒》（The Apprentice）。《学徒》本来要拿到那个档期。但我们的执行制片人真的为《办公室》争取到了它。我们做到了。Randy说，这在2008年5月就已经是我们内部拍摄记录的一部分了，那远在我们开始拍摄第五季之前。所以我们早就知道这件事要来了。
I also reached out to Greg Daniels.
Oh, yeah, what do you have to say?
He said this.
Oh, yeah.
This was a big deal.
Yeah.
Quote, we threw our biggest guns at it, which is why Paul Lieberstein wrote it.
That makes sense.
我还联系了Greg Daniels。哦，是的，他怎么说？他说这个。哦，是的。这是一件大事。是的。引用他的话：“我们拿出了最强的武器，这就是为什么Paul Lieberstein写了这一集。”这说得通。
It's a fantastic script.
I texted Paul yesterday just a few couplets of dialogue.
I was like, this is perfection.
I'll tell you what I texted him later.
Well, Paul had been with us since the very beginning.
He is one of our best.
It made total sense that he should be this episode.
Right.
这是一个很棒的剧本。我昨天给Paul发了短信，发了几句对白。我说，这简直是完美。我稍后告诉你我给他发了什么。好吧，Paul从一开始就和我们在一起。他是我们最好的编剧之一。他来写这一集完全合情合理。没错。
I got curious.
Okay.
And I started doing a little digging.
Angela, the script for this episode was 95 pages long.
I know.
I looked through it and I was like, what is this phone book I'm reading?
Oh, my God.
It's stress relief.
我很好奇。好的。我开始做了一点挖掘。Angela，这一集的剧本有95页长。我知道。我翻看了一下，当时想，我读的是什么电话簿吗？天哪。这是《压力缓解》。
The candy bag.
Okay, the candy bag, our alts, all of our alt dialogue?
Yeah, all the extra jokes that they didn't put in the script but that they want us to maybe shoot.
Oh, my God.
How long was it?
Lady, it was 207 pages long.
They had 207 pages of extra jokes.
Yeah.
糖果袋。好的，糖果袋，我们的备选，我们所有的备选对白？是的，所有他们没放进剧本但想让我们可能拍摄的额外笑话。天哪。有多长？Lady，它有207页长。他们有207页的额外笑话。是的。
On the ready to go.
Yep.
Oh, my God.
So I thought we should tell everyone that this episode took us nine days to shoot.
It was a very, very big deal.
Greg also said that because we were running after the Super Bowl,
it created a scrutiny from the network that was not normally present on our show.
Oh, yeah.
准备好了。是的。天哪。所以我认为我们应该告诉大家，这一集我们拍了九天。这是一件非常非常大的事。Greg还说，因为我们在超级碗之后播出，这引起了电视网前所未有的审查。哦，是的。
Lots of notes.
Lots of opinions.
Sure.
This is a big piece of real estate.
This will come up again later.
Mm-hmm.
Should I move us to Fast Fack number three?
Yes.
很多意见。很多看法。当然。这是一块很大的地盘。这以后还会提到。嗯哼。我能进入速记事实第三条吗？好的。
All right.
Fast fact number three, Greg told us that because there would be so many new eyes on this episode, new viewers,
that they had to figure out a storyline that would appeal to both current office viewers
and new ones. And they also had to find a way to kind of reintroduce everyone's characters
so that new viewers could follow along. They really tried to stay away from existing storylines.
So, for example, there's no movement or mention of the Angela Andy Dwight Love Triangle.
Right. There's nothing about the company is struggling and there might be layoffs.
No, there's nothing very complicated. This is a very simple idea that can hook everybody.
好的，速记事实第三条，Greg告诉我们，因为这一集会有很多新面孔，新观众，他们必须想出一个既能吸引现有《办公室》观众又能吸引新观众的故事情节。他们还必须找到一种方法来重新介绍每个人的角色，以便新观众能跟上。他们真的尽量避开了现有的故事情节。例如，没有关于Angela、Andy和Dwight三角恋的进展或提及。没错。没有关于公司陷入困境可能裁员的内容。不，没有什么非常复杂的东西。这是一个非常简单的想法，可以吸引所有人。
Yes.
But they especially had to figure out how do we start this episode?
How do we hook these new viewers and make them stay for the whole hour?
Right.
So Greg had this idea.
What if an office weirdo who wanted people to listen to his safety ideas actually caused a fire emergency?
He was like, you don't have to know who's who.
It has a lot of energy and a lot of physical comedy.
是的。但他们特别需要弄清楚我们该如何开始这一集？我们如何吸引这些新观众并让他们看完整整一个小时？没错。所以Greg有了这个想法。如果一个办公室怪人因为想让大家听他的安全建议而引发了一场火灾紧急情况会怎样？他说，你不需要知道谁是谁。它有很强的能量和很多肢体喜剧。
There you go.
I mean, that is brilliant.
Greg is brilliant because instantly you're hooked.
Everyone has an office like idiot that is going to like take matters in their own hands or something.
I thought it was amazing.
Well, we will break down this epic cold open after the break.
But I have one more thing to say.
Okay.
就是这样。我是说，这太天才了。Greg很天才，因为你立刻就被吸引住了。每个人都有一个办公室白痴，会自作主张做些什么。我觉得这太棒了。好吧，我们休息后会拆解这个史诗般的开场。但我还有一件事要说。好的。
This is a bonus fast fact.
Okay.
Did you notice the main titles?
Of course I did.
Everybody is in them.
I know.
This is the first time that our main titles,
featured the entire cast. It was so cool. We were so excited. We all cheered when we watched it.
这是一个额外速记事实。好的。你注意到片头了吗？我当然注意到了。每个人都在里面。我知道。这是我们的片头第一次展示了整个演员阵容。太酷了。我们太兴奋了。我们看的时候都欢呼了。
Oh my gosh. I remember my family too, because like everyone in my family who had never seen the show
saw it because it was after the Super Bowl. And we were in the main titles. It was really exciting.
It was special. The whole thing was special. I mean, there are all these little milestones
along the way as we're doing this rewatch and as we're looking back at our journey. I'm
realizing all of these firsts. And I would have never imagined I'd be on a TV show that would run
after the Super Bowl. The Super Bowl is such a big deal. I remember commercial auditioning and everyone
wanted like a Super Bowl commercial spot. If we could just, I still, I still, I'm like, oh, come on.
Yeah. Let me throw a Dorito at your head and you catch it in your mouth and it ricochets off
天哪。我也记得我家人，因为我家里所有没看过这部剧的人都看了，因为它是在超级碗之后播出的。我们还出现在了片头字幕里。这真的很令人兴奋。这很特别。整件事都很特别。我的意思是，在我们重温这部剧并回顾我们的旅程时，一路上有这么多小的里程碑。我意识到所有这些“第一次”。我从来没想过我会出演一部在超级碗之后播出的电视剧。超级碗可是件大事。我记得试镜广告时，每个人都想得到一个超级碗的广告位。如果我们可以，我仍然，我仍然，我在想，噢，拜托。是的。让我往你头上扔个多力多滋，你用嘴接住，然后它从天花板上弹开。
the ceiling. Super Bowl lad. You heard it here, Doritos. Office lady.
throw Doritos and catch them.
We'll do it.
Jenna will do a cartwheel.
She's very athletic.
What?
Better start working on my cartwheels.
I guess so.
天花板。超级碗小伙。你们在这里听到了，多力多滋。办公室女士。扔多力多滋并接住它们。我们会做的。珍娜会做一个侧手翻。她非常有运动天赋。什么？最好开始练习我的侧手翻了。我想是这样。
Well, ladies, should we take a break?
And then when we come back, everyone, get ready.
Buckle in because we have an epic cold open with an epic cold open breakdown.
We do.
It's going to be good.
All right, you guys, let's get right to it.
First of all, you should know, we reached out.
to a ton of people to share with us how they made this cold open happen.
好了，女士们，我们要休息一下吗？然后当我们回来时，大家，准备好。系好安全带，因为我们有一个史诗般的冷开场，还有对这个史诗般冷开场的深度解析。我们会的。这会很棒。好了，伙计们，让我们直接进入正题。首先，你们应该知道，我们联系了很多人，让他们和我们分享他们是如何制作这个冷开场的。
It was fascinating, actually, finding out.
We knew our part, right?
But we're like, well, how did camera do it?
How did they?
Like, so many things.
So many things to capture.
So Randy Cordray, you guys know we love Randy.
He told us they had several planning sessions, right?
事实上，了解这些过程非常迷人。我们知道我们自己的部分，对吧？但我们在想，摄影组是怎么做到的？他们是怎么做到的？就像，有太多的事情了。有太多的东西要捕捉。所以兰迪·科德雷，你们知道我们爱兰迪。他告诉我们他们进行了几次策划会议，对吧？
With all the department heads, we had our director, Jeff Blitz, cinematographer
Randall Einhorn.
They had to walk through this whole dance that we did.
with the camera stunts, animal trainers, script supervisor of Veda, like tracking the continuity.
And then our rock star, First AD, Kelly Cantley, she then broke it down into smaller moments.
Dean Holland, our editor, who edited this sequence, he told me he was also brought in on those
planning sessions. He said he got so much footage, but that it was actually really, really well
organize and pretty easy to edit because they planned so well. Oh, way to go, guys. Randy told us that we spent
和所有的部门主管一起，我们有导演杰夫·布里茨，摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩。他们必须走一遍我们做的整个舞蹈动作。包括摄像特技、动物训练师、剧本主管维达，比如追踪连续性。然后我们的摇滚明星，第一副导演凯利·坎特利，她把它分解成更小的时刻。我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德，他剪辑了这个序列，他告诉我他也参加了那些策划会议。他说他得到了很多素材，但实际上组织得非常好，剪辑起来相当容易，因为他们计划得太好了。噢，干得好，伙计们。兰迪告诉我们，我们花了一整天拍摄这一个场景。
an entire day shooting this one whole day. To be exact, it was Thursday, December 11th. Oh, yeah.
And we had tons of safety meetings, all the safety stuff. I remember we did not shoot this in order.
Right. We shot it out of order and some of that was for safety reasons. Yeah. Let's describe it and then we'll go back and we will
break it down piece by piece.
Here's your overview, everybody.
Here's your overview of the cold open.
The first shot is Dwight opening his desk, and he sort of motions to the camera all sneaky,
and he's got lighter fluid in what looks like to be a blow torch.
确切地说，那是12月11日星期四。噢，是的。我们进行了大量的安全会议，所有的安全事项。我记得我们不是按顺序拍摄的。对。我们乱序拍摄，其中一些是为了安全原因。是的。让我们描述一下，然后我们会回去，我们会一点一点地分解它。这是你们的概述，各位。这是冷开场的概述。第一个镜头是德怀特打开他的办公桌，他偷偷地向摄像机示意，他手里拿着打火机油，看起来像是一个喷火器。
Yeah.
So you know something's up.
Something Dwightish.
He goes in the hallway, and he's kind of hiding out, and he's whispering to camera,
and he starts, like, jamming the doors.
He puts a key in, he hammers it shut.
He puts his little wood wedges under and blow it.
torches the door handle and starts his speech. Yeah. He says that nobody paid attention to his fire safety
是的。所以你知道有事情要发生了。一些德怀特式的事情。他走进走廊，他有点躲起来，他在对摄像机耳语，他开始，比如，堵住门。他插上一把钥匙，他把它钉死。他把他的小木楔子塞在下面，然后用喷火器烧门把手，并开始他的演讲。是的。他说没有人注意他的消防安全研讨会。
seminar. He blames himself for using PowerPoint. Right. And that experience is the best teacher. So he will
teach his co-workers proper fire emergency procedure the hard way. And you guys, today's cigarettes are
going to save lives. Yeah. As he smokes a cigarette and then tosses it into a trash can and immediately a fire
starts. But no one notices it first. No one notices smoke piling in under the door. And everybody's just
quietly working. And it's really frustrating Dwight. So he's like, do you guys smell something? And Angela's so
snarky. He's like, did you bring your jerky in today? This is it. But Jenna, Pam notices it the way I
react in moments like this. You notice she didn't say fire? She was like,
there's a, oh my, it's a, she freezes. Yeah. Michael starts yelling forever.
他责怪自己使用了PPT。对。而经验是最好的老师。所以他要以硬方式教他的同事正确的火灾紧急程序。伙计们，今天的香烟将拯救生命。是的。当他抽了一根烟，然后把它扔进垃圾桶，火立刻就烧起来了。但起初没有人注意到。没有人注意到烟雾从门下涌进来。每个人都在安静地工作。这让德怀特很沮丧。所以他说，你们闻到什么了吗？安吉拉非常刻薄。他说，你今天带了牛肉干来吗？就是这样。但珍娜，帕姆注意到了，就像我在这种时刻的反应一样。你注意到她没说“火”吗？她是说，有一个，噢，天哪，它是一个，她僵住了。是的。迈克尔开始大喊让每个人保持冷静。德怀特在喊正确的安全程序，但人们在恐慌。突然间完全混乱了。听起来是这样的。噢，天哪。好的，它发生了。每个人保持冷静。程序是什么，大家？程序是什么？保持冷静。等等，等等，等等，等等，每个人都要冷静下来。不，不，不，迈克尔，不。正是如此。好吧，在混乱中，安吉拉从文件柜里拿出一只猫。噢，是的。奥斯卡逃到了天花板上。我知道你会有很多关于那个的事情要告诉我们。
everyone to stay effing calm. Dwight is kind of shouting proper safety procedures, but people are panicking.
It's suddenly total chaos. This is what it sounded like. Oh my God. Okay, it's happening.
Everybody stay calm. What's the procedure, everyone? What's the procedure? Stay fucking car.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, everybody is to calm down. No, no, no, Michael, no.
Exactly. Well, amid all the chaos, Angela gets a cat out of a file cabinet.
Oh, yeah.
Oscar escapes up into the ceiling.
I know you're going to have a lot to tell us about that.
是的。然后迈克尔砸碎了会议室的窗户。凯文要确保他在火灾期间能拿到零食。他像是在砸自动售货机。然后德怀特点燃了一堆鞭炮。是的。对此，埃德·赫尔姆斯饰演的安迪说了我在这个冷开场中最喜欢的一句台词，那就是，“火在向我们射击。”
Yeah.
And then Michael smashes a window in the conference room.
Kevin is going to make sure he's getting snacks during the fire.
He's like busting up the vending machines.
And then Dwight lights a bunch of firecrackers.
Yep.
To which Ed Helms is Andy says my favorite line in this cold open, which is,
The fire is shooting at us.
吉姆在把复印机撞向一扇门。最后，德怀特拉响了火警警报。为什么？因为斯坦利心脏病发作了。正是如此。是的。这太疯狂了。是的。整件事都很疯狂。我们是怎么做到的？好吧，我们有很棒的人。这就是我们做到的方式。我们和我们的摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩谈过，关于他们究竟是如何捕捉到所有这些时刻的。我们联系了他。这是他要说的。是的，我和杰夫·布里茨以及第一副导演凯利·坎特利密切合作，协调我们究竟要如何拍摄，因为有很多移动的部分，很多移动的碎片。它不想让人觉得需要50台摄像机来拍摄。
Jim is like ramming.
the copy machine into a door. Finally, Dwight pulls the fire alarm. Why? Because Stanley's having a heart
attack. Exactly. Yes. It's insane. Yeah. The whole thing is insane. How did we do it? Well, we had amazing people.
That's how we did it. We spoke to our cinematographer, Randall Einhorn, about how exactly they captured all
these moments. We reached out to him. Here's what he had to say. Yeah, I worked really closely with Jeff Litts.
and R.D. Kelly Cantley to coordinate how exactly we're going to shoot that,
because there was a lot of moving parts, a lot of moving pieces.
It didn't want to feel like it needed 50 cameras filming it.
它总是想让人觉得只有两台摄像机在拍摄，而且他们还在努力拍摄。所以有很多事情要解决，因为发生的事情太多了。但因为我们能够在一些摄像机快速移动时进行剪辑，我们能够把它拼凑在一起，看起来就像是一整块。因为当摄像机从一个东西平移到另一个东西时，如果你做得对，你可以让它看起来像是你可以创建一个剪辑点，你从一个片段的结尾平移，
It always wants to feel like there's just two cameras filming it, and they're struggling to film it.
So it was a lot to work out because there was so much going on.
But because we're able to cut on some of the camera swishes, we're able to piece it together
so it looked like it was one piece.
because as a camera's panning from one thing to another,
if you're doing it right,
you can make it look like you can create an edit point
where you're panning from the end of one piece
然后你平移到另一个，另一个片段的开始，这真的是它的做法。这就是我们如何把它全部拉在一起，让它看起来像是一个疯狂的镜头。我在这次重温中学会了，嗯，我们多久使用一次那种快速剪辑。它是我们的朋友。
and you're panning into another,
the beginning of another piece is really kind of how it's done.
That's how we all pull it all together
and made it look like it was a one frantic take.
I have learned doing this rewatch
Mm-hmm.
How often we used that whip cut.
It was our friend.
显然，这就是这个冷开场发生的原因。女士，我们收到了很多关于这个冷开场的粉丝提问，所以为什么我不把它们过一遍呢？好的。我们在剧集开头说了，雷恩在做他所有的恶作剧，锁门和放火。我们有一个来自杰登·C的粉丝提问。德怀特在那些把手上用的是真的喷火器吗？看起来确实是。为什么我们不让雷恩·威尔逊告诉我们呢？
Clearly, it's why this cold open happened.
Lady, we got a ton of fan questions about this cold open, so why don't I go through them?
Okay.
We said at the top of the episode, Rain's doing all his mischief with the locking of the doors and setting the fire.
We had a fan question from Jaden C.
Was Dwight using a real blow torch on those handles?
It certainly looked like it.
Why don't we let Rain Wilson tell us?
雷恩，你有什么要说的？是的，那是一个真正的喷火器。那不是CGI火焰。他们那里有很多安全官员。你知道，消防队长在那里，还有一个特效协调员。把手确实变得非常热。你知道，现在他们可能会做CGI，甚至可能用CGI让门把手变红一点。但那完全是真的。
Rain, what you got to say?
Yes, it was a real live blowtorch.
It was not a CGI flame.
They had a lot of safety officers there.
You know, a fire marshal is there and a special effects coordinator.
And the handles actually did get very hot.
You know, nowadays they'd probably do CGI and maybe even make the door handle a little red with the CGI.
But that was all completely real.
我不敢相信他们给了他一个真正的喷火器。我的意思是，如果你回顾一下他们在剧集中给雷恩的那些真实的东西。他们早该知道，回到邓迪奖颁奖典礼时，他们给了他那个操作键盘。就像，他用放屁键做了什么。不要给那个家伙真实的东西。不要给那个家伙真实的东西。好吧，是的，所以真正的喷火器，还有什么？好吧，我们有另一个粉丝提问。人们想知道雷恩是否真的在抽烟。罗·希特·R想知道垃圾桶里的烟是否是真的。这是雷恩要说的。
I can't believe they gave them a real.
real blowtorch. I mean, if you look back over the things they gave Rain that were real in episodes.
They should have known going back to the Dundies when they gave him that operating keyboard.
Like, just what he did with a fart key. Don't give that guy real things. Don't give that guy real things.
Well, yeah, so real blowtorch, what else? Well, we had another fan question. People wanted to know if
Rain was really smoking. And Roe Hit R wanted to know if it was.
real smoke in the trash can.
Here's what Rain had to say.
那是我抽的一根真正的香烟，我点燃了它，我把它扔进了带有纸的垃圾桶里，但我认为他们就像在摄像机移开的那一秒跑进去，扔了一些水并把它熄灭了，你在垃圾桶里看到的火是专家创造的，多亏了特效的魔力。在整个剧集中有这么多惊人的细节，我记得保罗·利伯斯坦指导我。我想是他写的，但保罗在很多细节上起了很大作用，关于我如何抽烟，我如何随意地扔掉香烟，他在脑海中可视化了它，楔子是如何被钉在门下的，以及所有的细节，我口袋里的锤子等等。所以伟大的保罗·利伯斯坦，也就是托比，在整个《办公室》中，特别是在这一集和这个冷开场中，确实发挥了巨大的创造性作用。
It was an actual cigarette
that I smoked and lit
and I threw it in the garbage can
with the paper, but I think they like
ran in the second that camera
panned away and tossed in some water
and put it out and the fire that
you see in the trash can is expertly
哇，我不知道。我不知道保罗是所有这些节拍的幕后推手，所有那些火灾时刻的舞台设计。是的，我也不知道。另外，珍娜，顺便说一句，我从来没有在电影或电视剧中抽过烟，那将是一场灾难，因为我不知道怎么抽烟，而且会很明显。我不知道怎么假装抽烟。好吧，对于我们所有的技术宅来说，兰迪为我详细解析了他们究竟是如何制造垃圾桶里的火和烟雾的。所以雷恩是对的，对吧，他们熄灭了你看到的火，但为了制造那种涌入的烟雾，那是通过由罗恩·内里领导的特效团队创造的。对于烟雾，他使用了一个带有微量乙二醇浓度的水蒸气发生器。我想乙二醇是让水蒸气在空气中停留时间更长的东西。兰迪说它没有气味，并且得到了SAG和NBC环球安全部门的安全批准。什么是乙二醇？噢，不。谷歌一下？
created due to the magic
of special effects.
There are so many amazing
details throughout the episode that Paul
Lieberstein, I remember guiding me
through. I think he wrote it, but Paul was very instrumental in a lot of the details about how I
smoked and how I casually tossed the cigarette and he had it kind of visualized in his mind,
how the wedges get hammered under the door and all the details, the hammer in my pocket
你可以谷歌一下？谷歌一下？它是什么？是乙二醇吗？好的，有两种乙二醇。噢。有丙二醇。好的。
and stuff like that. So the great Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, really played a great creative
part throughout the entirety of the office and especially in this episode and this cold open.
Wow, I didn't know that. I didn't know Paul was.
behind all those beats, all the like staging of the fire moments. Yeah, me either. Also, Jenna,
just on a side note, I've never had to smoke a cigarette in a movie or TV show and it would be a
disaster because I don't know how to smoke a cigarette and it would be so clear. I wouldn't know how to
be like faky smoky. Well, for all of our like kind of techy nerds out there, Randy broke down for me
exactly how they did make that fire in the trash can, that smoke. So Rainier,
然后有乙二醇。一个是好人，一个不太好吗？我想差不多。我认为乙二醇是像防冻液里的那种东西。噢。它有一种甜味。这就是它有毒的原因，对吧？
was right, right, they extinguished the fire that you saw, but then to create that smoke billowing in,
that was created by a special effects team led by Ron Neri. And for the smoke, he used a water
vapor generator with a minute concentration of glycol. And I guess the glycol is what keeps the
water vapor hanging in the air a bit longer. Randy said it had no odor and it was approved safe by
both SAG and NBC Universal Safety Department.
What is glycol?
Oh, no.
Google it?
对动物来说。舔你的狗去舔它。对。他们总是说不要舔你的防冻液。他们总是这么说。对狗来说。狗就像，我们不明白你在说什么。不，猫也喜欢它。
You can Google it?
Google it?
What is it?
Is it glycol?
Okay, there's two glycol.
Oh.
There's propylene glycol.
Okay.
你必须小心。现在，丙二醇是一种通常用作食品添加剂的物质。它在很多化妆品和卫生产品中，包括，我想，一些牙膏。噢。所以那是我们用的那个。我的意思是，我想是这样。好吧，我想。其中一种乙二醇也可以用作某种纤维。
And then there's ethylene glycol.
Was one a good guy and one's not great?
I guess kind of.
I think the ethylene glycol.
glycol is the stuff that's in like antifreeze.
Oh.
And it has like a sweet taste.
That's what it's poisonous, right?
我不认为我们有时间结束关于乙二醇的深度挖掘，但我们很好奇。所以我假设既然SAG和NBC环球说它是安全的，那么我们就用了安全的那个。我们用了安全的那个。看看我们。我们很好。我们在这里。下一个粉丝提问来自麦基·S。史蒂夫在说“保持冷静”时是即兴发挥的吗？
To animals.
To lick your dog to lick it.
Right.
They're always saying don't lick your antifreeze.
They're always saying that.
To dogs.
The dogs are like, we don't understand you.
No, cats love it too.
不。不过有一点点。好吧，那是史蒂夫，对吧？我的意思是，他得到了所有的剧本，但有时他会在那一刻即兴发挥。剧本里是这么写的。噢，天哪，它发生了。让我过去。让我过去。
You've got to be careful.
Now, propylene glycol is a substance that's commonly used as a food additive.
It's in a lot of cosmetic and hygiene products, including, I think, some toothpaste.
Oh.
So that's the one we used.
I mean, I guess so.
Well, I think.
One of the glycols can also be used as some sort of a fiber.
保持冷静。保持冷静。保持冷静。然后迈克尔猛烈地挤到前面。我想我们做到了。我的意思是，非常准确。我们还有更多的粉丝提问，安吉拉。杰登·C想知道迈克尔把投影仪扔进窗户多少次。好吧，他先用椅子，对吧？没错。它没有破。兰迪说对于那个，我们用了一块有机玻璃。因为他们不想让它破。他们想让他第一次尝试不成功。是的。然后他们用易碎玻璃替换了有机玻璃，它非常逼真地破碎了，但它从来不会以尖锐或危险的方式破碎。我有一个有趣的小事实给你。在好莱坞的旧时代，这被称为糖玻璃。我知道，珍娜，因为我和我爸爸参观了一个旧的西部片场，他们就像，所有那些家伙被扔出酒吧和沙龙的窗户，那是糖。糖！你可以吃它。我想现在他们不用糖做了，但兰迪说老派的人仍然称它为糖玻璃，尽管现在它被称为易碎玻璃。
I don't think we have time to end the moment deep dive glycol, but we were curious.
So I'm assuming that since SAG and NBC Universal said it was safe, then we used the safe one.
We used the safe one.
Look at us.
We're fine.
We're here.
Next fan question is from Mikey S.
Did Steve improvise when he said stay effing calm?
好的。兰迪还告诉我们，杰登，回答你的问题，他们一次就拍成了。投影仪的一次投掷就打破了易碎玻璃。就是这样。杰登还想知道凯文打破自动售货机多少次。我联系了布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。他说他认为大约用了两到三次拍摄。他们用了同样的易碎玻璃。
No.
A little bit, though.
Well, that's Steve, right?
I mean, he got everything scripted, but sometimes he would zhuz in the moment.
Here's what it said in the script.
Oh, God, it's happening.
Let me through.
他说它每次都破了，但他们不得不额外做几次，只是为了让某个摄像机移动正确。你知道，他们在做快速剪辑。对。为了让它看起来很疯狂。对。现在，接下来，女士，我想我们应该讨论这个没有人写信问过，但却如此史诗般的时刻。我不敢相信没有人写信问过它。我知道你说的正是那个时刻，因为它对我们片场的所有人来说都是一件大事。
Stay calm.
Stay effing calm.
And then Michael violently pushes his way through to the front.
I think we did it. I mean, very accurately. We have more fan questions, Angela. Jaden C. wants to know how many times did Michael throw the projector into the window.
Well, he starts with the chair, right? That's right. It does not break. And Randy said that for that, we used a plane of plexiglass.
Because they didn't want it to break. They wanted his first attempt not to go well. Yes. Then they replaced the
Plexiglass with breakaway glass, and it shatters very realistically, but it never shatters in a
也许人们没有意识到这一点，因为克里斯·沃克曼是一个多么厉害的人。所以我们说的是当凯文带领邓德-米夫林员工跑过厨房并撞倒我们的摄像师兰德尔·艾因霍恩的那一刻。伙计们，这是一个完全的错误。是的。我们当时想，噢，天哪，兰德尔倒下了。但只持续了几秒钟。我们联系了兰德尔，因为我们必须从他的角度听这个故事。当布莱恩撞倒他时。我记得当我倒着跑过休息室时，
sharp or dangerous way.
I have a little fun fact for you.
In the olden days of Hollywood, this was known as candy glass.
I know that, Jenna, because I got a tour of an old Western set with my dad, and they were like,
all those windows that guys get thrown out the bars in and the saloon, that was candy.
Candy!
You could eat it.
I guess nowadays they don't make it out of candy, but Randy said old schoolers still call it candy glass, even though now it's called breakaway glass.
饰演凯文的布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳正向我跑来，因为他正疯狂地试图从那里出去。他只是不停地向我跑来，跑着并追上我，追上我。我正倒着拿着摄像机跑。他离得太近了，我想他撞到了我。我倒在了地上。我倒下了。但我的摄像师克里斯·沃克曼，一个非常强壮的家伙，用一只手臂抓住了我，用一只手臂抓住了摄像机，把我扶了起来。我是一个200磅重的家伙。摄像机有近40磅重。克里斯只是把我举了起来。我甚至不知道我是否撞到了地面。但那个我倒下又站起来的镜头实际上进入了剧集。所以谢谢你，克里斯·沃克曼，把我扶起来。谢谢你，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳，撞到我并拍出了这么酷的镜头。
Okay.
And Randy also told us, Jaden, in answer to your question, they got it in one take.
One throw of the projector broke the breakaway glass.
There you go.
Jaden would also like to know how many times did Kevin break the vending machine.
I reached out to Brian Baumgartner.
He said he thought it took about two to three takes.
They used that same breakaway glass.
好吧，安吉拉，我觉得我们也需要听听布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳关于这个时刻的看法。割草机和被割草的人。正是如此。我们需要一个观点对立面。好吧，谢谢你，兰迪。我，你知道，我想取笑你把故事弄错了，但你称赞了我，而且把故事说得百分之百正确。我的意思是，看，我后面有人在跑，好吗？所以我必须跑过我面前的任何东西，否则我自己就会被撞倒。
He said it broke every time, but they had to do it a few extra times just to get a certain camera movement right.
You know, they were doing the whip cuts.
Right.
To make it look frantic.
Now, next up, lady, I thought we should discuss this moment that no one wrote in about, but that was so epic.
I can't believe no one wrote in about it.
I know exactly the moment you're talking about because it was such a big deal to all of us on set.
但实际上，仔细想想，这是第一次有人告诉我我跑赢了任何人。我的意思是，你当时正倒着跑，扛着摄像机。但是的，我不得不把你撞倒。看，我记得的是，是的，据我回忆，你一直倒在背上。对我来说，从眼角余光看，看起来像是克里斯·沃克曼，一只手把你扶起来，把你放回脚上。就像你这样的专业人士，好吧，你只是继续拍摄。我很高兴它进入了剪辑，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。
And maybe people don't realize that because of what a badass Chris Workman is.
So what we're talking about is the moment when, led by Kevin, the Dunder-Mifflin employees are running through the kitchen and take down our camera operator, Randall Einhorn.
Guys, this was a total mistake.
Yeah.
We were like, oh, my God, Randall's down.
But only for a few seconds.
We reached out to Randall because we had to hear this story from his.
perspective. When Brian mowed him down. I remember when I was running backwards through the breakroom
也许人们没有意识到这一点，因为克里斯·沃克曼太厉害了。我们谈论的是凯文带领邓德·米夫林员工跑过厨房，撞倒我们的摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩的那一刻。伙计们，这完全是个意外。是的。我们当时想，天哪，兰德尔倒下了。但只持续了几秒钟。我们联系了兰德尔，因为我们必须从他的角度听听这个故事。当布莱恩撞倒他时。我记得当时我正背对着跑过休息室
and Brian Baumgartner, who plays Kevin, was running at me because he's frantically trying to get
out of there. And he just kept running on me, running and gaining on me and gaining on me. And I'm
running backwards with the camera. And he just got so close that I think he hit me. And I hit the
ground. I went down. But my camera says, Chris Workman, who's really strong guy, just caught me with one
arm caught me and the camera with one arm and put me back on my feet. And I'm like a 200-pound guy.
The camera's nearly 40 pounds. And Chris just lifted me up. I didn't even know if I hit the ground.
But that shot of me going down and getting back up actually made the show. So thank you,
Chris Workman, for picking me up. And thank you, Brian Baumgartner, for running into me and making
而饰演凯文的布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳正向我跑来，因为他正拼命想逃离那里。他一直追着我，越跑越近，越跑越近。我扛着摄像机倒着跑。他离我太近了，我想他撞到了我。我摔倒了。我倒下了。但我的摄像师克里斯·沃克曼，一个非常强壮的人，用一只手抓住了我，连人带摄像机一起抓住，又把我扶了起来。我大概有200磅重。摄像机有近40磅重。克里斯就这样把我提了起来。我甚至不知道自己是否真的倒地了。但那个我倒下又站起来的镜头确实被剪进了节目里。所以谢谢你，克里斯·沃克曼，把我扶起来。也谢谢你，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳，撞到了我并制造了
such a cool shot. Well, Angela, I felt like we also needed to hear from Brian Baumgartner about this moment.
The mower and the mode.
Exactly.
We needed a point counterpoint.
Well, thank you, Randall.
I, you know, I wanted to make fun of you for getting the story wrong, but you complimented me and got the story 100% right.
I mean, look, I had people running behind me, okay?
So I had to run over whatever was in front of me, or I would have gotten run over myself.
这样一个很酷的镜头。嗯，安吉拉，我觉得我们也需要听听布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳对这一刻的看法。割草机和模式。没错。我们需要一个观点和反观点。好吧，谢谢你，兰德尔。你知道，我本来想嘲笑你把故事讲错了，但你夸奖了我，而且把故事讲得百分之百正确。我是说，听着，我身后有人在跑，好吗？所以我必须撞开面前的任何东西，否则我自己就会被撞倒。
But actually, come to think of it, it's the first time that anyone has ever took.
told me that I've outrun anyone.
I mean, you were running backwards carrying a camera.
But yeah, I had to put you down.
And look, the thing I remember is, yes, you went all the way to your back, as I recall.
And for me, out of the corner of my eye, it looked like Chris Workman, one hand picked you up, put you back on the feet.
And like the pro that you are, well, you just kept filming.
I'm so happy that it made it into the cut, and it's one of my favorite episodes.
但实际上，仔细想想，这是第一次有人告诉我我跑赢了别人。我是说，你当时扛着摄像机倒着跑。但没错，我确实把你撞倒了。听着，我记得的是，是的，据我回忆，你整个人都仰面朝天了。对我来说，用眼角余光看，看起来像是克里斯·沃克曼单手把你扶起来，让你重新站稳。而你像个专业人士一样，继续拍摄。我很高兴这个镜头被剪进了正片，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。
It aired after the Super Bowl, obviously, and that was a big deal for me.
And yeah, one of our funniest cold opens for sure.
Well, lady, I just remember that moment so vividly because I do remember,
Randall is down.
What do we do?
And then Randall is up.
I guess we continue.
But it was amazing to me.
显然，它是在超级碗之后播出的，这对我很重要。没错，这绝对是我们最搞笑的开场之一。好吧，女士，我记得那一刻非常清晰，因为我记得兰德尔倒下了。我们该怎么办？然后兰德尔又站起来了。我想我们继续吧。但这对我来说太神奇了。
And that's the only time it happened, and that's the take we used.
Chris Workman, man. He is a machine.
All right, now, I think we need to discuss the thing that we got the most mail about.
Oh, yeah?
Save Bandit.
Save!
And it was the last thing on our call sheet for the day.
All the rest of us had gone home.
这是唯一发生的一次，我们用了那个镜头。克里斯·沃克曼，天哪。他简直是个机器。好了，现在，我想我们需要讨论一下我们收到最多邮件的事情。哦，是吗？救救班迪特。救命！那是我们当天通告单上的最后一项。我们其余的人都已经回家了。
I know they did this because it was so complicated.
They wanted you to have the set to yourself.
I was not there.
Angela, please tell us.
How did you pull this?
off. Okay, so here's the thing, guys. We had to have a lot of rehearsals. You should know,
on the day when there was a lot of the chaos and we were all running around, I was there,
but the cat didn't work those moments, okay? Yeah. The cat did have to work one moment, Jenna,
我知道他们这样做是因为它太复杂了。他们想让你独自拥有这个场景。我当时不在场。安吉拉，请告诉我们。你是怎么做到的？好吧，事情是这样的，伙计们。我们必须进行大量的排练。你应该知道，在那天混乱的时候，我们都在四处奔跑，我在场，但猫在那些时刻并不配合，好吗？是的。猫确实需要配合一个时刻，珍娜，
with all of us, where I opened the drawer and you reveal. You guys are all in the background for that
moment. And I had to actually pick the cat up and walk over to where I would have tossed it.
And that was it. That's all I had to do with the cat, with the group there.
Jenna, this cat was massive. It looks big. I'm like, did you cast the biggest cat they had?
Did you see the big one in the corner and say, we want that, dude? Just taking it out of the drawer with the chaos, not even doing anything with it. Just picking it up and taking it to my spot, the cat was like, I'm out of here.
So I was really glad when we actually filmed the stunt part that you guys were all gone.
Right.
Oh my gosh.
和我们所有人一起，我打开抽屉，你揭露了它。那一刻你们都在背景里。我不得不真的把猫抱起来，走到我本该把它扔过去的地方。就是这样。这就是我和猫在一起时要做的全部，当时大家都在那里。珍娜，这只猫太大了。它看起来很大。我在想，你们是不是选了他们能找到的最大的猫？你们是不是在角落里看到了那只大的，然后说，我们要那只，伙计？在混乱中把它从抽屉里拿出来，甚至没对它做什么。只是把它抱起来带到我的位置，猫就像是，我要离开这里了。所以我真的很庆幸当我们真正拍摄特技部分时，你们都走了。对。天哪。
Less activity for the cat to deal with.
The cat was already like, where am I?
What's going on?
All right.
So a lot of things went in to make this happen.
And I'm going to share with you some stuff that Randy Cordray and Jeff Blitz shared with me.
But then I'm going to tell you my personal memories.
So I guess in the script there were a few alts about how the cat got in the ceiling.
猫要处理的活动少了。猫当时已经在想，我在哪？发生了什么？好吧。所以很多事情促成了这一切。我将与你们分享兰迪·科德雷和杰夫·布里茨与我分享的一些东西。但我会告诉你们我个人的记忆。我想剧本里有几个关于猫是怎么进天花板的替代方案。
Jeff Blitz fought really hard to have the moment where the cat goes up in the ceiling and then out a different part of the ceiling.
Yes.
That was the thing he fought for.
He said to do this, though, it would involve a pair of matching cats and two trainers in the ceiling,
one to catch bandit one and one to drop Bandit 2 through a different ceiling panel.
So the idea originally was that you would go on a search for twin cats.
Identical looking cats.
Yes.
杰夫·布里茨非常努力地争取让猫进入天花板然后从天花板的另一个部分出来的时刻。是的。那是他争取的事情。他说要做到这一点，需要一对匹配的猫和两个在天花板里的训练师，一个抓班迪特1号，另一个通过不同的天花板面板放下班迪特2号。所以最初的想法是你去寻找双胞胎猫。长得一模一样的猫。是的。
And Randy said that we worked with an excellent animal training company out of Silmar, California.
Their name is Bob Dunn's Animal Services.
And our specific cat trainer for this stunt and many more episodes was Denise Sanders.
She was fantastic.
I love Denise.
And Randy would want you guys to know that we took the safety of not only the humans on set, but also the animals.
Took it very seriously.
Well, that was Randy.
兰迪说我们与加利福尼亚州希尔马的一家优秀的动物训练公司合作。他们的名字是鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司。我们这次特技和许多其他剧集的特定猫训练师是丹妮丝·桑德斯。她太棒了。我爱丹妮丝。兰迪想让你们知道，我们不仅非常认真地对待片场人类的安全，也对待动物的安全。那是兰迪。
Randy is a real animal lover.
And he advocated for all of us, fur babies and real people.
Okay.
So Jenna, my memory is we had two rehearsal days for this stunt.
Wow.
Yeah.
One was just like a preliminary blocking, but then the second one was like, okay, we have to practice this as if we're doing it.
And our biggest rehearsal, it was me, Jeff Blitz, Randy Cordray, Greg Daniels.
兰迪是一个真正的动物爱好者。他为我们所有人，毛孩子和真正的人类辩护。好吧。所以珍娜，我的记忆是我们为这个特技排练了两天。哇。是的。一次只是初步的走位，但第二次就像是，好吧，我们必须像真的在做一样练习。我们最大的排练，有我、杰夫·布里茨、兰迪·科德雷、格雷格·丹尼尔斯。
I think some of the writers were there.
I think Dean might have been there, our editor.
Everyone that was going to be involved in this moment, Oscar, the trainer up in the ceiling.
There was a lot of people, actually, for this rehearsal.
And if I miss some of you guys, there was more people.
than you would imagine. I had a stunt woman named Katina Waters because they actually didn't want me
tossing the cat up in the ceiling, right? They wanted a professional animal wrangler stunt person.
Yeah. That makes sense. Right. What if I got it wrong? Right. I'm not a professional animal wrangler
我想一些编剧也在场。我想迪恩可能也在，我们的剪辑师。所有将参与这一刻的人，奥斯卡，天花板上的训练师。实际上，这次排练有很多人。如果我漏掉了你们中的一些人，还有更多人。比你想象的要多。我有一个名叫卡蒂娜·沃特斯的特技替身，因为他们实际上不想让我把猫扔进天花板，对吧？他们想要一个专业的动物驯兽师特技演员。是的。这说得通。对。如果我弄错了怎么办？对。我不是专业的动物驯兽师
stunt person. You're not a professional animal thrower? I am not. But as we started blocking the moments of the scene,
the cat wrangler, Denise, was like, you guys, we can't toss a cat up in the ceiling.
You know, we can't toss it up. We can't toss it out. There is no tossing of cats, guys,
because not that it will harm the cat. This isn't a very high distance or anything like that.
It won't physically harm them. It won't physically harm the cat. And then she used this phrase,
Jenna, that was like a scratch on the record player. She said, because it will blow out the cat.
And this is clearly a cat wrangler term. It will be a.
blow out the cat. We all, all of us went, huh? Blow out the cat. And then Greg goes, because Greg's such
特技演员。你不是专业的扔猫人？我不是。但当我们开始排练场景的动作时，猫驯兽师丹妮丝说，你们，我们不能把猫扔进天花板。你知道，我们不能把它扔上去。我们不能把它扔出来。伙计们，没有扔猫这回事，因为不是说这会伤害猫。这不是什么很高的高度之类的。它不会在物理上伤害它们。它不会在物理上伤害猫。然后她用了这个短语，珍娜，就像唱片机上的划痕。她说，因为它会“吹掉”猫。这显然是一个猫驯兽师的术语。它会“吹掉”猫。我们所有人，我们所有人都说，哈？吹掉猫。然后格雷格说，因为格雷格是如此
an inquisitive-minded person, he's like, I'm sorry, what does that mean to blow out the cat? Yeah.
And she said, it will ruin its career. Now, is that because just the stress of performing that stunt
would make it so that the cat wouldn't be able to maybe go to work again? Like, the cat would be okay
physically, but it would be stressful and they couldn't be sure that it would be a trainable cat in the
future? That's what I'm hearing. Yeah, that's exactly what we all heard, which is the cat will physically
be fine, but you might make it so it's afraid and we won't be able to train it. Got it. Right? Okay. Right.
So it could live out its life as someone's pet, but it's not going to be a working cat anymore.
Not a stunt cat anymore. Okay. But this is her job, right? Like this cat working, this is her livelihood.
一个好奇心强的人，他说，对不起，吹掉猫是什么意思？是的。她说，这会毁了它的职业生涯。那么，这是因为表演那个特技的压力会使猫以后可能无法再工作了吗？就像，猫在身体上会没事，但它会有压力，他们不能确定它将来会是一只可训练的猫？这就是我听到的。是的，这正是我们所有人听到的，也就是说猫在身体上会很好，但你可能会让它害怕，我们将无法训练它。明白了。对吧？好吧。对。所以它可以作为某人的宠物度过余生，但它不再是一只工作猫了。不再是一只特技猫了。好吧。但这是她的工作，对吧？就像这只猫在工作，这是她的生计。
Right. And so Greg, like, as a problem solver, he was like, well, what would it cost to retire the cat?
Could we pay you and retire the cat? And that way you don't lose your income in this cat.
Uh-huh. She didn't want to retire the cat. This is a very high-earning cat. This is a very good cat.
It's the largest cat they have. It's the largest stunt cat. Clearly the largest physically and the largest monetary stunt cat.
So they came up with this idea. They made it work. This is what the animal trainer said that they could do.
we would toss up into the ceiling a fake cat, okay?
Okay.
Yes, a fake cat.
对。所以格雷格，作为一个问题解决者，他说，好吧，让猫退休要花多少钱？我们可以付钱让你让猫退休吗？这样你就不会失去这只猫的收入。嗯哼。她不想让猫退休。这是一只高收入的猫。这是一只非常好的猫。它是他们拥有的最大的猫。它是最大的特技猫。显然在身体上是最大的，也是经济上最大的特技猫。所以他们想出了这个主意。他们让它成功了。这就是动物训练师说他们能做的。我们会把一只假猫扔进天花板，好吗？好吧。是的，一只假猫。
And then up in the rafters of the ceiling would be a trainer that would then gently be holding a real cat and release it onto my desk, which was just a few feet below.
Okay, I think I got it.
Tossing cat up, blows out cat.
Tossing cat up blows out cat.
Can't throw a cat.
Dropping cat.
Onto its feet.
Totally fine.
然后天花板的椽子里会有一个训练师，他会轻轻地抱着一只真猫，然后把它释放到我的桌子上，那离我只有几英尺远。好吧，我想我明白了。扔猫上去，吹掉猫。扔猫上去吹掉猫。不能扔猫。放下猫。落在它的脚上。完全没问题。
Totally fine. You know what? I have to say, Sunny Cat actually enjoys a good toss. Sometimes I'm doing laundry on the bed, and he'll come up, and he likes it when I give him a big hoist onto the pile of laundry. And then he'll jump down and I'll do it again.
Sunny, you could have been banned. Sunny could have been banned it. He's like, I'll do it. I'll do the toss.
Yes, Sunny should have been band it. Well, here's the deal. Randy even went to extra measures to make sure the cat would be fine.
when they were going to drop it on my desk.
He and the animal trainers and our stunt guy, Eric Sulky,
they came up with this huge inflatable safety airbag that would decelerate and gently
catch the falling cat.
It was described as like falling into feathers.
完全没问题。你知道吗？我不得不说，桑尼猫实际上很享受被扔。有时我在床上洗衣服，他会过来，他喜欢我把他高高地举到那堆衣服上。然后他会跳下来，我再做一次。桑尼，你本可以成为班迪特的。桑尼本可以成为班迪特。他就像是，我会做的。我会做那个扔的动作。是的，桑尼本该是班迪特的。好吧，事情是这样的。兰迪甚至采取了额外的措施来确保猫会没事。当他们要把它扔到我的桌子上时。他和动物训练师以及我们的特技演员埃里克·萨尔基，他们想出了一个巨大的充气安全气囊，可以减速并轻轻接住下落的猫。它被描述为像掉进羽毛里一样。
And we did some practice runs and the trainers signed off on it.
It was fine.
The cat wasn't traumatized at all.
They hid this airbag in the corner of my accounting desk with like papers and stuff.
but there was a cat airbag on my desk, okay?
And the ceiling panel had breakaway foam rubber, all right?
So it was all very cushy, cushy.
But now...
我们做了一些练习，训练师签收了它。没问题。猫一点也没有受到创伤。他们把这个气囊藏在我的会计桌角落里，用纸之类的东西盖住。但我的桌子上有一个猫气囊，好吗？天花板面板有易碎的泡沫橡胶，好吗？所以一切都非常柔软，柔软。但现在……
I just want to say they did all of this and then gave Rain a real blowtorch.
I know.
They had an inflatable airbag cushion for this enormous cat.
But now, Jenna, enter in the people that make fake animals.
I'm scared.
I found them fascinating.
So, like, you know, if you have a show like CSI and there's a dead body, these are your people.
They make fake humans.
我只想说他们做了这一切，然后给了雷恩一个真正的喷灯。我知道。他们为这只巨大的猫准备了一个充气安全气囊。但现在，珍娜，有请制作假动物的人。我很害怕。我觉得他们很迷人。所以，你知道，如果你有一个像《犯罪现场调查》这样的节目，有一个死尸，这些人就是你的目标。他们制作假人类。
They make fake animals.
Jenna, they had to meticulously match the exact cat that we were tossing in the ceiling.
And it was a rush job.
Randy said this fake cat cost $12,000.
Oh my God.
I know.
And I want you to know that thing was one of the scariest things I've ever seen, held or touched.
First of all, it had these yellow eyes that would just look at you.
他们制作假动物。珍娜，他们必须一丝不苟地匹配我们扔进天花板的那只确切的猫。而且这是一个赶工的任务。兰迪说这只假猫花了12,000美元。天哪。我知道。我想让你知道，那东西是我见过、拿过或摸过的最可怕的东西之一。首先，它有那种会盯着你看的黄眼睛。
And then the fur felt real.
But when you picked it up, it was gelatinous.
So, like, flop, like as you held it.
Oh, my God.
Like, imagine, like, flopping a towel over your arm, a big thick towel.
It was like smushy.
It was frightening.
I, we started kind of pranking with it.
然后毛皮摸起来是真的。但当你把它捡起来时，它是胶状的。所以，就像，当你拿着它时会晃动。天哪。就像，想象一下，把一条毛巾搭在你的手臂上，一条厚厚的大毛巾。它就像软绵绵的。很吓人。我，我们开始用它搞恶作剧。
Like, I set it on Oscar's desk, and he walked up and he was like, oh, God.
I had to, like, start covering its face with a piece of paper because the thing was so creepy to look at.
Where is it now?
I don't know.
NBC owns it somewhere, right?
They paid for it.
By the way, this is just the cat stuff.
We haven't even gotten to the fact that Oscar has a whole bit he has to do.
比如，我把它放在奥斯卡的桌子上，他走过来，就像，哦，天哪。我不得不开始用一张纸盖住它的脸，因为那东西看起来太诡异了。它现在在哪？我不知道。NBC拥有它，在某个地方，对吧？他们付了钱。顺便说一句，这只是猫的东西。我们甚至还没谈到奥斯卡有一个他必须做的完整片段。
Oh, yeah.
Right?
So when we actually got to the day to shoot the stunt, I go over to the drawer, I pull out the cat.
Now, they said my dialogue and everything, I still had to be yelling.
Okay?
So I opened the drawer and you'll hear in the take I say to the cat, it's okay.
like I'm trying to like be like, I'm not a bad person.
I lift up this enormous cat and then I have to go to my spot where Oscar's going in the roof
哦，是的。对吧？所以当我们真正到了拍摄特技的那一天，我走到抽屉前，拉出猫。现在，他们说我的台词和一切，我仍然必须大喊大叫。好吧？所以我打开抽屉，你会听到在那个镜头里我对猫说，没关系。就像我试图表现得像，我不是一个坏人。我抱起这只巨大的猫，然后我必须走到奥斯卡要进屋顶的地方
and they wanted so they could do that swishy cut.
Yeah.
They wanted me to take the cat.
I'm holding it to my chest.
They wanted me to swing the cat back behind me and then swing it up over my head and stop.
This is the real cat.
The real cat.
Okay.
他们想要这样他们就可以做那个快速剪辑。是的。他们要我拿着猫。我把它抱在胸前。他们要我把猫甩到身后，然后把它甩过头顶并停住。这是真猫。真猫。好吧。
The real cat gets the swinging motion.
Swinging okay. Swinging approved. Swinging approved. While I'm yelling, right? I'm sure the cat loved that.
You know what cats love? Screaming. And swinging. Yeah. This cat probably weighed 20 pounds. I'm not exaggerating at all. It was enormous. Just the swinging and getting it to my stopping point. It was like, oh, God. And then I stop and I hold it in the air. Freeze. Then they yell cut. And it.
In comes my stunt woman in the same outfit.
She takes real cat.
She holds it in the air.
I step away because what she's going to do with the cat, Jenna, is kind of do the second motion
where it appears like she's tossing, but she doesn't toss the cat.
真猫得到了那个甩动的动作。甩动，好吧。甩动被批准。甩动被批准。当我在大喊大叫时，对吧？我相信猫喜欢那样。你知道猫喜欢什么吗？尖叫。还有甩动。是的。这只猫可能重20磅。我一点也不夸张。它太巨大了。只是甩动并把它带到我的停止点。就像，哦，天哪。然后我停下来，把它举在空中。冻结。然后他们大喊停。然后。我的特技替身穿着同样的衣服进来了。她拿着真猫。她把它举在空中。我走开，因为她要对猫做的事，珍娜，是做第二个动作，看起来像是她在扔，但她并没有扔猫。
Okay.
But she kind of gives it a little air, but not a lot of air.
And this was like they don't want you to get all scratched up.
She knows how to give like a little thing.
Yeah.
They had to give the idea of the motion.
Right.
好吧。但她给了它一点空气，但不是很多空气。这就像他们不想让你被抓伤。她知道怎么给一点点东西。是的。他们必须给出那个动作的想法。是的。对。比我的甩动多。明白了。好吧。然后当然我们。必须得到一个镜头，我必须拿着假猫做和特技替身一样的动作。我必须看着她，把假猫扔进天花板，对吧？是的。他们把所有这些拼凑在一起。所以珍娜，我很久以前就和杰夫·布里茨谈过这一刻，因为我清楚地记得
More than my swing.
Got it.
Okay.
And then of course we.
had to get a take where I had to take Faky Cat and do the same motion as the stunt woman. I had to
watch her and toss Faky Cat in the ceiling, right? Yes. They pieced all of that together.
So Jenna, I had talked to Jeff Blitz about this moment a while back because I distinctly remember
当我们拍摄它时，两只猫从天花板里出来，而不是一只。怎么会？怎么会有两只猫出来？那是我的记忆。我当时想，等等，我是疯了吗？我和剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德谈过。我说，迪恩，你是不是必须剪掉一只猫？因为我知道两只猫下来了。我记得看到两只猫。他说，没有。所以我找了杰夫·布里茨。他说，是的，安吉拉，两只猫下来了。我当时想，什么？他说，在我们用的那个镜头里，本该接住假猫的训练师错过了。哦。所以然后在动作开始时，假猫从另一边出来，还有真猫。哦，天哪。两只猫。两只猫撞到了桌子上。杰夫说，幸运的是，摄像机的位置，它只拍到了一只猫。
when we filmed it two cats coming out of the ceiling instead of one. How? How did two cats come out?
That's my memory. And I was like, wait, am I crazy? And I talked to Dean Holland, who edited. I was like,
Dean, did you have to see GI out one cat? Because I know two cats came down. I remember seeing two cats.
He was like, no. And so I talked to Jeff Blitz. And he goes, yes, Angela, two cats came down.
And I was like, what? He said, on the take we used, the trainer that was supposed to catch the faky cat missed.
Oh. And so then on action, faky cat came out the other side and real cat.
Oh, my gosh. Two cats. Two cats hit the desk.
And Jeff said, luckily, the way the camera was positioned, it only caught one cat.
我想当你观看时那是真猫。看起来像是一只真猫下来了。是的，因为它撞到了，然后它跑开了。而假猫只会发出“噗”的一声。是的。对吧？是的。所以就是这样。
And I think it's the real cat when you watch.
It looks like a real cat comes down.
Yeah, because it hits and it kind of runs off.
Whereas Faky Cat just would have gone plop.
Yes.
Right?
So there you go.
一只猫上去了。两只猫下来了。但我们拍到了那个镜头。它需要所有那些人和所有的操纵，但它进入了剧集。安吉拉，那太神奇了。我不知道那个故事的所有细节。我坐在座位的边缘。我绝对喜欢那个。你们，疯狂的事情是花了我那么长时间才讲完那个故事，但它发生在五秒钟内。哦，天哪。当我们真正拍摄它时，它太快了。所以就像，我，抽屉，猫，甩动，走开，踩上，假猫。哦，天哪，两只猫，对一只做出反应。好吧，你提到在这一切过程中还有别的事情发生，那就是奥斯卡进出天花板。
One cat went up.
Two cats came down.
But we got the shot.
It took all those people and all that maneuvering, but it made it in the episode.
Angela, that is amazing. I did not know all the details of that story. I was on the edge of my seat. I absolutely loved that.
You guys, the crazy thing is it took me that long to tell that story, but it happened in five seconds.
Oh, my God. When we actually filmed it, it was so quick. So it was like, me, drawer, cat, swing, step out, step on, fake a cat. Oh my God, two cats, react to one.
Well, you mentioned that there was something else going on during all this, which was Oscar going in and out of the ceiling.
是的，那是另一场磨难。兰迪告诉我们，让奥斯卡进入天花板的特技的那部分是特技中最具挑战性的另一部分，因为我们的场景建造方式没有任何可以攀爬的地方。就像实际的轻质吊顶，它是用电缆悬挂的。是的，非常细的索具线。那是假天花板，伙计们，因为我们的场景在一个巨大的摄影棚里。是的。所以实际上，邓德米夫林办公室上方只是空气。如果你走到外面，你可以抬头看，只能看到这些支撑假天花板的电线。
Yes, that was a whole other ordeal.
Randy told us that that part of the stunt of getting Oscar up into the ceiling was the other most challenging part of the stunt because there was nothing to climb into in the way that our set was built.
Like the actual lightweight drop ceiling, it was suspended from cables.
Yeah, very thin rigging wires.
It was faky ceiling, guys, because our set was inside a humongous soundstage.
Yeah.
So actually, above the Dundermifflin offices was just air.
If you walked outside, you could look up and just see these wires holding faky ceiling.
是的。所以他说在拍摄前几周，我们的制作设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格和施工协调员蒂姆·詹姆斯必须完全重新设计天花板。他们必须像建造我们本来没有的椽子，对吧？是的，它必须足以支撑不仅是奥斯卡，还有所有的特技人员。他说那天有两名特技协调员、动物人员、奥斯卡、奥斯卡的特技替身和一名NBC环球安全协调员。他们都在天花板里。你能想象那个人的工作日吗？
Yeah.
So he said in the weeks prior to filming this, our production.
designer Michael Gallenberg and construction coordinator Tim James had to completely re-engineer the ceiling.
They had to like build rafters basically that we didn't have, right? Yeah, and it had to be enough
to support not just Oscar, but all of the stunt personnel. He said on the day there were two stunt
coordinators, the animal people, Oscar, Oscar stunt double, and an NBC Universal Safety coordinator.
They're all up in the ceiling.
Can you imagine that guy's day at work?
我不能。就像，他通常不和我们在一起。他现在就在我们的天花板里。我可以告诉你，我不得不抬头看天花板，它看起来很拥挤。我明白为什么有人可能会在猫飞上去时错过它。好吧，我们收到了亚历克斯·M的一个粉丝问题。奥斯卡真的掉进天花板了吗？是的。
I can't.
Like, he's not normally with us.
He's just up in our ceiling now.
I can tell you that I had to look up into the ceiling and it looked crowded.
I get why someone might have missed a cat as it flew up there.
Well, we got a fan question from Alex M.
Did Oscar really fall through the ceiling?
Yes.
嗯，是的，也不是，对吧？我们使用奥斯卡和大量的特技替身完成了它，对吧，安吉？是的。所以我联系了奥斯卡，我说，奥斯卡，你必须告诉我们关于天花板的一切。我想他经常被问到这个问题。他发来了这个音频片段。我有一个特技演员。我有一个摩洛哥人。他，他，我想他是摩洛哥人。他，他来自太阳马戏团。他比我矮一点。他是一名特技演员。我想他是从洞里跳出来，落地时做了精彩的翻滚。我做了一半。
Well, yes and no, right?
We pulled it off using both Oscar and a lot.
stunt double, right, Ange? Yeah. So I reached out to Oscar, and I was like, Oscar, you got to tell us
everything about the ceiling. I guess he gets asked this a lot. And he sent in this audio clip.
I had a stuntman. I had a Moroccan. He was, he was, I think he was from Morocco. He was, he was from
Cirque Soleil. He was a little shorter than me. And he was a stuntman. And I think he was jumping out
from the hole and doing wonderful tumbles when he hit the ground.
I did half of it.
他做了非常困难的部分。这是一个非常有趣的场景，非常复杂。我记得在其中一个镜头里，我让史蒂夫笑了，因为我从屋顶下来的方式之一，在其中一个镜头里，他们在上面有一根大杆子，它把我慢慢地从洞里降下来。那是一种有趣的下来方式。当我与史蒂夫进行眼神交流时，
He did the really hard part.
It was a very funny scene, very complicated.
I remember in one of the shots,
I made Steve laugh because one of the ways that I was coming down from the roof,
on one of them, they had a big bar up there,
and it lowered me slowly through the hole.
And that was a funny way to come down.
And when I made eye contact with Steve,
只是挂在那里，面无表情。当然，他笑了。然后他们想出了，把我带下来的方法，那是一个跳下来。但首先我只是，就像，我们尝试的事情之一只是，就像，被从那个东西上降下来，这说不通，但非常有趣。你记得吗？我记得。我也记得。它非常奇怪地像《黑客帝国》。确实。奥斯卡慢慢地出来。就像非常慢。那部汤姆·克鲁斯慢慢把自己降下来的电影叫什么？《碟中谍》。就像那样。奥斯卡就像慢慢地从天花板里出来。它看起来
just hanging there with a straight face.
Of course, he laughed.
And then they figured out,
way to bring me down, which was a leap down. But first I would just, like, one of the things we tried
were just, like, being lowered down from the thing, which didn't make sense, but was very funny.
Do you remember that? I remember it. I do too. It was very weirdly matrixy. It was. And Oscar was
slowly coming. Like very slowly. What was that Tom Cruise movie where he slowly lowered himself down?
Mission impossible. It was like that. Oscar was like slowly coming out of the ceiling. It looked
疯狂。奥斯卡当然没有笑场，因为他从不笑场。但我们笑了。我们其余的人都觉得，我们不可能继续下去，好像那是物理上可能的。如果史蒂夫笑了，你知道它看起来很荒谬。好吧，让我为任何想跟上的人分解一下。在2分38秒，真正的奥斯卡站在他的桌子上，他推开了天花板瓷砖。在2分43秒，对于奥斯卡真正跳起来并把自己拉进天花板的那一拍，那是他的特技替身。你会注意到你看不到他的脸。他的替身名字叫阿尔-丁·纳穆。为了完成这个，我想阿尔-丁必须在他的奥斯卡服装下穿上安全带。它有一根电缆，穿过他的安全带到一个滑轮，由
crazy. And Oscar, of course, did not break because he never broke. But we did. And all the rest of us were like,
we can't possibly continue as if that's physically possible. And if Steve broke, you know it looked
ridiculous. Well, let me break it down for you for anyone who wants to follow along. At two minutes
38 seconds, the real Oscar is standing on his desk and he pushes up the ceiling tile.
At two minutes 43 seconds for that beat of Oscar actually jumping up and pulling
himself into the ceiling, that's his stunt double. You'll notice you don't see his face. His double's
name was Al-Din Namu. And to pull this off, I guess Al-Din had to wear a safety harness underneath his
Oscar wardrobe. And it had this cable that went up through his harness to a pulley that was manned by
天花板里的两个人操作。在他跳跃之后，这些人会像用这个滑轮把他吊上去。你必须信任天花板里的人，不是吗？然后在2分48秒，我们再次看到真正的奥斯卡。他在脚手架上向下看。他也由安全带和电缆固定，只是为了确保安全。最后，在3分33秒，奥斯卡似乎打破了克里德桌子附近厨房旁边的另一个天花板面板。那是他特技替身的腿在踢。克里德的反应对我来说太搞笑了。
two guys in the ceiling. And after he would jump, these guys would like hoist him up using this
pulley. You got to trust the guys in the ceiling, don't you?
Then at 2 minutes 48 seconds, we see the real Oscar again.
He's up there in the scaffold looking down.
He was also secured by a harness and a cable, just to make sure.
Finally, at 3 minutes 33 seconds, Oscar appears to break through another ceiling panel over by the kitchen near Creed's desk.
That's his stunt doubles legs kicking.
Creed's reaction was so hilarious to me.
抱歉，继续。但在4分06秒，那是特技团队把真正的奥斯卡扔到地板上的时候。场景里有这么多拍子。这么多。我们甚至还没谈到斯坦利的突发心脏病。哦，天哪。在这一切结束时，他躺在地上。迈克尔就像告诉他他不能死。他不能死。他把一个钱包塞进他的嘴里。是的，迈克尔在大喊巴拉克·奥巴马是总统。
Sorry, go on.
But at four minutes, six seconds, that is when the stunt team dropped real Oscar onto the floor.
So many beats of the scene. So many.
We haven't even talked about Stanley's heart attack.
Oh, my gosh.
At the end of all of this, he's on the ground.
And Michael is like telling him he can't die. He can't die. He's shoving a wallet in his mouth.
Yeah, Michael's yelling Barack Obama's president.
你不能死，斯坦利。我们收到了梅根·G的一个粉丝问题。莱斯利·大卫·贝克在我的大学演讲时说，迈克尔把钱包塞进他嘴里的那个场景是即兴创作的。这是真的吗？女士，我在剧本里查过了。它不在那里。它以他说你不能死，巴拉克·奥巴马是总统结束。那个钱包片段是在当天发生的。
You can't die, Stanley.
We got a fan question from Megan G.
Leslie David Baker spoke at my college and said that the scene where Michael puts the wallet in his mouth was improvised.
Is this true?
Lady, I looked it up in the script.
It is not there.
It ended with him saying you can't die, Barack Obama is president.
That wallet bit was on the day.
哦，天哪。好吧，我有一个让我轻笑的粉丝问题，珍娜。艾玛·N写信说，梅雷迪思在1分49秒左右带着那种脏兮兮的问号棕色靴子。在整个冷开场中，有没有任何删除的场景或关于这个的解释？哦。好吧，艾玛，你让我好奇了。我去了你的时间码。你没错。我拍了一张照片。看，珍娜。我会把它放在故事里。那是什么？我看了这张照片，我想，艾玛，我认得这些靴子。我敢打赌那是凯特的UGG靴子，服装组给我们放在桌子底下，当我们很冷的时候穿。那不是梅雷迪思的靴子。所以我给凯特发了短信。我说，凯特，在《压力缓解》中，当德怀特差点烧毁大楼时，你抓住了
Oh, my gosh.
Well, I have a fan question that made me chuckled, Jenna.
Emma N. wrote in and said, Meredith has these kind of dirty question mark. Brown boots she's carrying at around one minute 49 seconds. And throughout some of the cold open, was there any deleted scene or explanation about this? Oh. Well, Emma, you got me curious. I went to your time code. You are not wrong. I took a photo. Look, Jenna. I'll put it in stories. What is that? And I looked at this photo and I was like, Emma, I recognize these boots.
I would bet money that those are Kate's Ugg boots that wardrobe gave us to keep under our desk
when we were so cold.
They're not Meredith's boots.
So I texted Kate.
I said, Kate, in stress relief when Dwight almost burns down the building, did you grab
你桌子底下的实际UGG靴子吗？粉丝们在问。我把照片发给她，她回信说，哈哈，我抓住了。所以我们得到的指示显然是每天。每个人都很恐慌，他们都在抓他们的东西。他们想离开大楼。她说，我抓住了我的UGG靴子。它们实际上并不脏。
your actual Ugg boots from under your desk?
Fans are asking.
And I sent her the picture and she wrote back, ha, ha, ha, I did.
So the direction we were given was clearly every day.
Everyone's panicking and they're grabbing their things.
They want to get out of the building.
And she said, I grab my Ugg boots.
They are actually not dirty.
它们是灰粉色的。哦。所以就是这样，艾玛。好眼力。女士，我想我们应该休息一下。那是冷开场。那只是冷开场。我们还有整集要分解，还有更多的事情要谈。
They're a dusty pink.
Oh.
So there you go, Emma.
Nice catch.
Lady, I think we should take a break.
That's the cold open.
That's just the cold open.
We still have this whole episode to break down and there is so much more to talk about.
好吧。我们会回来的。好吧。我们回来了。德怀特和迈克尔在公司开会，因为，嗨，德怀特差点烧毁了大楼，斯坦利心脏病发作了。所以他们必须与大卫·华莱士和人力资源的肯德尔会面。是的，肯德尔。客串警报。肯德尔由约翰·哈特曼扮演。现在，我们以前听说过肯德尔。他在之前的剧集中被提到过，我们听到了他的声音，记得吗，当他冲霍莉大喊时。哦，是的。所以约翰·哈特曼配了音。现在他在这里了。他在桌子旁。他太棒了。
All right.
We'll be back.
We are back.
Dwight and Michael are at a meeting in corporate because,
Hi, Dwight almost burned the building down and Stanley had a heart attack. So they're having to meet with David Wallace and Kendall from HR.
Yes, Kendall. Guest our alert. Kendall was played by John Hartman. Now, we've heard of Kendall before. He was mentioned in previous episodes, and we heard his voice, remember, when he yelled at Holly.
Oh, yeah. So John Hartman did the voice. And now here he is. He's at the table. He was so good.
你知道他们做那个小跑腿的片段，就像注意，他做了？你查过它是否是剧本写的吗？我查了，因为索尼娅·Y想知道。索尼娅，我也是。它是剧本写的。它是剧本写的，直到最后一个迈克尔再次注意。是的。他们有点增加了那个片段。
You know that bit where they do the little runner where like take heed, he did?
Did you look it up to see if it was scripted?
I did because Sonia Y wanted to know.
Sonia, so did I.
It was scripted.
It was scripted until the very last Michael Heeded again.
Yes.
They kind of added to the bit.
史蒂夫在最后增加了那个片段，但其他一切都是剧本写的。我实际上把那两句台词发短信给了保罗·利伯斯坦。我说，这是完美。你太搞笑了。然后史蒂夫在最后又加了一句，我可以看到雷恩试图不笑场。他实际上不得不低头看桌子。是的。在这个场景中，我还有两件事必须指出。
Steve added to the bit at the very end, but everything else is scripted.
I actually texted that couplet of dialogue to Paul Lieberstein.
I said, this is perfection.
You were so funny.
And then Steve at the very end added one more, and I can see Rain trying not to break.
He actually has to look down at the table.
Yeah.
There's two things I have to point out also in this scene.
首先，在这段对话中，德怀特说，想象一下我的挫败感，一个安全官，他们不听。对不起？安吉拉·马丁在篮球比赛中是安全官。她找不到急救箱，因为德怀特把它移走了。她说，我要告诉你多少次，我是安全官？这就像他们的第一次小争吵。是的。所以我不知道发生了什么。
First of all, in this dialogue, Dwight's like, imagine my frustration, a safety officer that they're not listening.
Excuse me?
Angela Martin was the safety officer in basketball.
She couldn't find the first aid kit because Dwight had moved it.
And she said, how many times do I have to tell you, I'm the safety officer?
It was like their first little, like, spat.
Yeah.
So I don't know what's happened.
德怀特显然没有放下这件事。他认为他是安全官。好吧，他不再是安全官了。不，他不是，因为迈克尔要成为安全员。这就是他称呼它的方式。他称它为安全员。我还有一件事必须指出，因为它让我笑得太厉害了，珍娜。我倒带看了这个拍子三次。
Dwight clearly has not let this go.
And he thinks he's the safety officer.
Well, he's not the safety officer anymore.
No, he's not because Michael's going to be the safety man.
That's what he calls it.
He calls it the safety man.
I have one other thing I have to point out because it made me laugh so hard, Jenna.
I rewound this and watch this beat three times.
当迈克尔站起来走出去，看着城市，你知道，然后他过来坐在肯德尔旁边，他就像把肯德尔挤过去，他说，请把它推下去，好吗？我没抓住那个。太搞笑了。那不在剧本里。请把它推下去。它不在剧本里。约翰和安迪·巴克利处理所有那些小瞬间的方式，哦，他们太棒了。好吧，当他们回到邓德米夫林时，斯坦利正回到办公室。迈克尔就像，嘘，安静，安静，安静。没有大声的噪音。
When Michael gets up and walks out and looks out at the city, you know, and then he comes and sits down next to Kendall, he like scoches Kendall over and he says, can you shove it down, please?
I didn't catch that.
It's so funny. That is not in the script.
Shove it down, please. It's not in the script.
And the way that John and Andy Buckley just rolled with all of those little moments, oh, they're so good.
Well, when they get back to Dunder Mifflin, Stanley is coming back into the office.
Michael's like, shh, quiet, quiet, quiet.
No loud noises.
是的。没有惊喜。是的。斯坦利有一个谈话头，他解释说过去他对人非常生硬，但医生说他需要找到一种更积极的方式与人相处，否则他会死。好吧，你注意到在那个谈话头里有一个蒙太奇，一个斯坦利对人非常生硬的瞬间的蒙太奇。是的，他失去冷静的瞬间。像这样的蒙太奇对我们的节目来说非常不寻常。它是为了给所有那些超级碗后的观众提供更多关于斯坦利角色的背景而添加的。
Yeah.
No surprises.
Stanley has a talking head where he explains that in the past he has been very abrupt with people,
but the doctor said he needs to find a more positive way to relate to people or he will die.
Well, you notice in that talking head there was a montage, a montage of moments of Stanley,
being abrupt with people. Yeah, of him losing is cool. A montage like this was very unusual for our show.
It was added to help give more context to the character of Stanley for all of those post-super Bowl viewers.
我正想说，因为纪录片不做蒙太奇。通常不做。通常不做。但当你在超级碗之后时，你会做。你会做。场景中另一个没有进入的拍子，它在删除的场景中，真的让我笑了，珍娜，是迈克尔，你知道，想要每个人都帮助斯坦。他正在敦促他们。所以这就是它的表现方式。安迪给斯坦利做了一张Inya歌曲的混合CD。哦。斯坦利就像，谢谢。迈克尔指派凯文做他的厕所伙伴。
I was going to say, because a documentary doesn't do a montage. Not normally. Not normally. But when you're
after the Super Bowl, you do. You do. Another beat of the scene that didn't make it in, it's in the deleted scenes that really made me laugh, Jenna, is that Michael, you know, wants everyone to help Stan
He's urging them.
So here is how that manifests.
Andy makes Stanley a mixed CD of Inya songs.
Oh.
Stanley's like, thanks.
Michael assigns Kevin to be his bathroom buddy.
好吧。正如凯文所说，以防你在马桶上心脏病发作。好吧。斯坦利就像，我可以自己去洗手间。谢谢。菲利斯只是看着他，无法停止微笑。她有一个非常甜蜜的谈话头，她说她认识斯坦利·哈德森很久了，他呼吸的方式，他那种大声的呼吸对她来说很舒缓。
Okay.
As Kevin says, in case you have a heart attack on the crapper.
And Stanley's like, I can go to the bathroom by myself.
Thank you.
Phyllis just looks at him and can't stop smiling.
And she has a really sweet talking head where she says she's known
Stanley Hudson a long time and the way he breathes, his sort of loud breathing is soothing to her.
真的很可爱。所以你有那个菲利斯的时刻。然后迈克尔说，别担心，斯坦利，我给你买了一个便携式除颤器。哦。然后试图把它放在他身上。每个人都像，不，不，不，不，不。哦，天哪。我记得拍摄那个。是的。然后迈克尔，就像，觉得它很有趣，想要，就像，把每个人都连接到它上面。他们就像，除颤。是的。你怎么说那个？除颤人们。每个人。然后凯文拿到了除颤器，作为一个玩笑把它放在梅雷迪思的座位上。梅雷迪思坐在上面，甚至没有注意到它，但她所有的头发都竖了起来。
It's really cute. So you have that Phyllis moment. And then Michael says, don't worry, Stanley,
I got you a portable defibrillator. Oh. And then tries to go put it on him. And everyone's like,
no, no, no, no, no. Oh, my gosh. I remember shooting that. Yes. And then Michael, like, thinks it's funny and
wants to, like, hook everyone up to it. They're like, defibrillate. Yes. How do you say that?
Defibrillate people.
Everybody.
And then Kevin gets the defibrillator and as a joke puts it on Meredith's seat.
Meredith sits on it and doesn't even notice it, but all of her hair goes up in the air.
那是我们必须做的另一个特技。他们必须让凯特·弗兰纳里的头发因静电而竖起来。哇。没有进入，但它非常有趣。迈克尔决心确保我们都知道如果斯坦利再次心脏病发作该怎么做。他要求我们所有人都进入会议室参加CPR课程。是的。一个他希望由他主持的课程，但显然你必须有一个实际的CPR训练师，否则你就得不到假人。是的，红十字会除非你有实际的
And that's another stunt we had to do.
They had to make Kate Flannery's hair rise up with static.
Wow.
Didn't make it in, but it was pretty funny.
Michael is determined to make sure that we all know what to do should Stanley ever have another heart attack.
He's asked us all to come into the conference room for a CPR.
class. Yes. A class he wishes he was running, but apparently you have to have an actual CPR trainer
or else you don't get the dummy. Yeah, the Red Cross won't give you the dummy doll unless you have an actually
训练有素的CPR教练，否则不会给你假人娃娃。我们收到了一个粉丝问题。好吧。来自斯蒂芬妮·H。我喜欢这个问题。谁扮演了CPR教练罗斯，为什么她如此完美？她绝对是。惊人。她的名字是罗宾·林奇。她是一名演员。我相信她是CPR教练。我联系了艾莉森·琼斯，她说她只是通过一般的选秀找到了罗宾，罗宾是他们看到的这个角色最合适的人选。她只是把它演得非常完美。她在那儿教CPR。这个办公室失控了，而她，她只是试图保持正轨。我确实滑进了她在Insta上的私信。是的，罗宾，我们试图联系你。我们想和你聊天，罗宾。如果你看到我们的信息，告诉我们。
trained CPR instructor. We got a fan question. Okay. From Stephanie H. I loved this question.
Who played Rose the CPR instructor and why is she so perfect? She is absolutely.
amazing. Her name is Robin Lynch. She is an actress. I believed she was a CPR trainer. I reached out to Allison Jones, and she said she found Robin through just a general casting call, and that Robin was by far the best person that they saw for the role. She just plays it so perfectly straight. She's there to teach CPR. This office goes off the rails, and she's,
She just tries to stay the course.
I did slide into her DMs on Insta.
Yeah, Robin, we tried to get a hold of you.
We wanted to chat with you, Robin.
If you ever see our message, let us know.
我们会和你聊天，并重新审视。我们应该谈谈在这个CPR课程中出错的所有事情吗？有很多。有很多。首先，它从凯文开始。凯文在20秒时放弃了。他就像，我放弃了。是的。
We'll chat you up and are revisited.
Should we talk about all the things that go wrong in this CPR class?
There are many.
First of all, it starts with Kevin.
Kevin gives out at 20 seconds.
He's like, I'm calling it.
Yeah.
然后罗斯就像，还有人想轮到吗？德怀特说他绝对不会。当摄像机从德怀特身上拉开以揭示房间时，珍娜，在9分50秒，我正在对摄像机外的人耳语不。你在说什么？你在说什么？我没有看罗斯。我正在看摄像机外的人。我不知道我在和谁说话。等等，让我问你这个问题。什么？你是在对另一个摄像机说不吗？我想是的，也许，但它看起来真的很奇怪。我感觉。拍摄了它，我要把它展示给你。我会把它放在故事里。但首先我要展示我的闺蜜，伙计们。好吧，准备好了？点击播放。
And then Rose is like, does anyone else want to turn?
And Dwight says absolutely he would not.
And as the camera is pulling back away from Dwight to reveal the room, Jenna, at nine minutes, 50 seconds, I am whispering to someone off camera no.
What are you talking about? What are you saying? I'm not looking at Rose. I'm looking at someone off camera. I don't know who I'm talking to.
Wait, let me ask you this question. What? Could you be saying no to the other camera?
I think so, maybe, but it looks really weird. And I feel.
filmed it and I'm going to show it to you. And I'll put this in stories. But first I'm going to show my BFF, guys.
Okay, ready? Hit play.
我不知道，但我非常明确地说不。看，看我的脸。不。我想，我不知道那是不是你在即兴创作，如果你是对着摄像机做。我想这是我对马特·索恩B摄像机做的即兴创作。是的。安吉拉在删除的场景中有一个谈话头，她说，我不会把我的嘴放在那个东西上。谁知道谁的嘴放在上面过？所以我认为我是在那个谈话头的基础上即兴创作的。但如果你捕捉到它，它看起来非常随机。这是一个非常，非常好的捕捉，女士。好吧，斯坦利要试一试，因为出于某种原因，迈克尔认为斯坦利应该学习如何复苏自己。我们可能不会总是在那里。对。然后，当然，以真正的迈克尔风格，他接管了会议，对吧？他现在要告诉他们如何做CPR。
I don't know, but I'm very pointedly saying no. And look, look at my face. No. I think, I don't know if
that's an improv you're doing, if you're doing it to camera. I think it's an improv that I'm doing
to Matt Sown B camera. Yeah. Angela in deleted scenes had a talking head where she's like, I am not putting
my mouth on that thing. Who knows whose mouth has been on it? So I think I was sort of improvising off
that talking head. But it looks really random if you catch it. It's a very, very good catch,
lady. Well, Stanley's going to give it a go because for some reason Michael thinks Stanley should learn
how to resuscitate himself. We might not always be there. Right. And then, of course,
in true Michael fashion, he takes over the meeting, right? He's going to tell them how to do CPR now.
对。他们做的一切都错了，罗斯说，听着，伙计们，你们需要每分钟100次。她建议他们随着比吉斯乐队的《Staying Alive》的曲调按压。起初，迈克尔把这与《I Will Survive》混淆了。但随后罗斯开始唱，Staying alive，你知道，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，Staying alive。然后安迪开始唱，Staying alive。凯利开始跳舞。它变成了一个舞会。如果你想听，我实际上有那个片段。让我们听听。啊，啊，啊，啊，Staying alive，Staying alive。嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，Stay in alive。Staying alive。Staying alive。嗯，嗯，嗯。你不能从我走路的方式看出来。我是个女人的男人，没时间说话。
Right. And they're doing it all.
wrong, Rose says, listen, guys, you need 100 beats per minute. And she suggests they pumped to the tune of
staying alive by the Bee Gees. At first, Michael confuses this with I Will Survives. But then Rose starts singing,
staying alive, you know, uh, uh, uh, uh, staying alive. Then Andy starts singing, staying alive.
Kelly starts dancing. It turns into a dance party. I actually have the clip if you want to hear it. Let's hear it.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, staying alive, staying alive. Uh, uh, uh, uh, stay in alive. Staying alive. Staying alive.
Uh, uh, uh.
You can't tell by the way I use my walk. I'm a woman's man, no time to talk.
话语很大，女人温暖，我出生以来就被踢来踢去。好吧，没关系。没问题。你不能看另一边。走开。放手。放手。好吧。过一天。Stay alive。Stay in alive。
Words are loud, women warm, been kicked around since I was born.
Well, it's all right. It's okay. You can't look the other.
away. Let it go.
Let it go.
Okay.
Get a day.
Stay alive.
Stay in a lie.
Staying alive。我是说，可怜的罗斯。我们收到了苏格兰梅根·D的一个粉丝问题。与红十字会女士的场景中是否有任何即兴创作，例如凯利的跳舞或安迪的唱歌？不，伙计们，这一切，所有的唱歌和跳舞，都是剧本写的。我们几乎按照剧本拍摄了这个场景。写得非常出色。我发现了是谁提出了这个想法。
Staying alive.
I mean, poor Rose.
We had a fan question from Megan D. in Scotland.
Was any of the scene with the Red Cross Lady improvised, such as Kelly's dancing or Andy's singing?
No, guys, this whole thing, all this singing and the dancing, it was all scripted.
and we followed this scene pretty much as written.
Brilliantly written.
I found out who pitched this idea.
哦，我知道。告诉他们。是珍·萨拉塔。是的。整个Staying alive CPR的想法来自她。她说她听说这是真的。她查了一下并交叉核对了。她说她再次交叉核对了，因为她不想在电视上播放，除非它是真的。然后她和我分享说，在《办公室》之前，她是《家居装饰》的编剧助理。
Oh, I know. Tell them.
It is Jen Salata.
Yes.
This whole staying alive CPR idea came from her.
She said that she had heard it was true.
She looked it up and cross-checked it.
She said she cross-checked it again because she didn't want to put it on TV unless it was true.
And then she shared with me that before the office, she had been a writer's assistant on home improvement.
编剧们做了一集，乔纳森·泰勒·托马斯角色发现他的喉咙上有一个肿块。在剧集中，结果发现那是甲状腺问题，对吧？珍说，她后来负责拆信，他们收到了所有这些家庭的信，说在看了那一集后，它帮助挽救了他们孩子的生命。因为他们的孩子有一个甲状腺肿块，因为那一集，他们去检查了。伙计们，自从这集《压力缓解》播出以来，人们已经使用这种CPR技术来挽救生命。他们确实挽救了。珍与我们分享说，她听说有一个人把一个女人从车里拉出来，并随着《Staying Alive》的曲调做CPR，因为这一集。我查过了。
And that the writers had done an episode where the Jonathan Taylor Thomas character found a lump on his throat.
And it turned out that it was a thyroid issue in the episode, right?
And Jen said that she was later in charge of opening the mail and they got letters from all of these families that said after watching that episode, it helped save their children's lives.
because their children had had a thyroid lump, and because of the episode, they got it checked out.
And guys, since this stress relief episode aired, people have used this CPR technique to save lives.
They have.
Jen shared with us that she heard about a guy pulling a woman out of a car and doing CPR to the tune of staying alive because of this episode.
I looked it up.
编剧们曾写过一集，乔纳森·泰勒·托马斯饰演的角色发现喉咙上长了一个肿块。在剧中，那最终被诊断为甲状腺问题，对吧？简说她后来负责拆阅观众来信，他们收到了所有这些家庭的来信，说在看了那一集之后，这帮助挽救了他们孩子的生命。因为他们的孩子也有甲状腺肿块，正是因为那一集，他们才去做了检查。伙计们，自从这集关于压力缓解的剧集播出以来，人们已经使用这种心肺复苏术挽救了生命。确实如此。简和我们分享说，她听说有一个人把一名女子从车里拉出来，并随着《Stayin' Alive》的节奏对她进行了心肺复苏，这都是因为这一集。我查过了。
It's true.
There's many articles.
I'm going to start with this one.
Okay, in January of 2019, Rolling Stones ran this story.
A scene from the office that dealt with first aid technique is credited to helping save a life after an Arizona man, despite having no CPR training, managed to resuscitate a woman in medical distress.
His name, interestingly enough, is Cross Scott.
Whoa!
Yeah, his last name is Scott.
这是真的。有很多文章。我要从这一篇开始。好的，2019年1月，《滚石》杂志刊登了这个故事。办公室里关于急救技术的一个场景被认为有助于挽救生命，当时一名亚利桑那州的男子，尽管没有任何心肺复苏（CPR）培训，却成功救活了一名身体不适的女性。有趣的是，他的名字叫克罗斯·斯科特（Cross Scott）。哇！是的，他的姓是斯科特。
So, he found an unconscious woman behind the wheel of her car that was rolling down a dirt road.
Wow. He smashed the window, got her out, and then he's quoted as saying, I've never prepared myself for CPR in my life. I had no idea what I was doing.
Thankfully, Scott had seen the episode of the office that dealt with CPR training and knew to do chest compressions to the cadence of staying alive.
They reached out to Courtney Slantaker, executive director of the Red Cross Southern Arizona chapter, and she told the Daily Star that if you don't do CPR, the victim will die. Don't be afraid to act.
do will help that victim and hopefully prevent a death. And Courtney confirmed that staying alive
is in fact the correct rhythm for chest compressions. Wow. Jen Salada, you got it right. Wow.
There's so many guys, but just recently in January of this year, the Today Show shared a story
about a four-year-old girl who collapsed while playing tag and her dad, Matt Uber, found her and started
所以，他发现一名失去知觉的女性坐在她那辆正沿着土路滑行的车里。哇。他砸碎了车窗，把她救了出来，然后他说：我这辈子从来没为心肺复苏做过准备。我根本不知道自己在做什么。谢天谢地，斯科特看过《办公室》里关于心肺复苏培训的那一集，知道要按照《Stayin' Alive》的节奏进行胸外按压。他们联系了红十字会南亚利桑那分会的执行主任考特尼·斯兰塔克（Courtney Slantaker），她告诉《每日星报》，如果你不进行心肺复苏，受害者就会死亡。不要害怕采取行动。你的行动将帮助受害者，并有望防止死亡。考特尼证实，《Stayin' Alive》确实是胸外按压的正确节奏。哇。珍·萨拉达（Jen Salada），你答对了。哇。伙计们，这样的例子太多了，但就在今年1月，《今日秀》分享了一个故事，一个四岁的小女孩在玩捉人游戏时晕倒了，她的父亲马特·尤伯（Matt Uber）发现了她并开始
chest compressions again to the tune of staying alive. And he's quoted as saying, when I was trying to
think about what to do about CPR, my mind literally went to that episode of the office where they
are doing CPR training and doing the compressions to the beat of staying alive.
I mean, that just got me choked up to imagine that father in that moment. I know. And then he had
something, anything he could do. I know. I know. And there's more. I know there's more stories.
but those two were two that stood out to me.
Amazing.
And one of the things that after reading some of these stories, Jenna, that people share is that how important knowing CPR is and that we should all learn CPR.
再次进行胸外按压，节奏也是《Stayin' Alive》。他说：当我试图思考该如何进行心肺复苏时，我的脑海里立刻浮现出《办公室》里他们进行心肺复苏培训并跟着《Stayin' Alive》的节拍进行按压的那一集。我的意思是，想到那位父亲在那个时刻的心情，我就哽咽了。我知道。而且他当时只能尽力而为。我知道。我知道。还有更多故事。我知道还有更多，但这两个故事最让我印象深刻。太棒了。珍娜，读完这些故事后，人们分享的一点是，了解心肺复苏有多么重要，我们都应该学习心肺复苏。
Yes, we have the staying alive so you know the beats, but that we should all learn our CPR safety because it really can save a life.
I know that when we had our son, our first child, Lee and I both did an infant CPR training.
Same. But we should do a refresher.
Yeah. Well, it's not over for Rose. She's not out of the woods yet. Things are about to get even crazier.
Yeah. She announces that we failed to save the life of our CPR dummy.
Dwight suggests that the next course of action would be to harvest the organs for organ donation.
And then he, of course, grabs the giant knife that is strapped to his calf.
Yeah. And he hacks into the dummy.
是的，我们有《Stayin' Alive》，所以你知道节拍，但我们都应该学习心肺复苏安全知识，因为它真的可以挽救生命。我知道当我们有了第一个孩子时，我和李都参加了婴儿心肺复苏培训。我也是。但我们应该复习一下。好吧，罗斯的故事还没结束。她还没脱离危险。事情即将变得更加疯狂。是的。她宣布我们没能救活我们的心肺复苏假人。德怀特建议下一步行动应该是摘取器官用于器官捐赠。然后，他当然抓住了绑在小腿上的那把大刀。是的。他砍向了假人。
his chest. Yeah, and we all freak out. Yeah, we freak out because then he cuts off the dummy's face
and puts it on his face. Like Silence of the Lambs. Yeah. We had some fan mail about it. People would
like to know how many CPR dummies were used in this episode. Hmm. Well, I asked Randy.
I know for sure. Rain really did cut into it because we watched him do it. Randy said we used three
CPR mannequins in total. Now, in a minute.
In a minute, David Wallace is going to say that they cost $3,500 each, but Randy said that was a little exaggerated.
He said there are some top-end dummies that come with very sophisticated features like articulating heads and heartbeat simulators.
Those cost at the time around $1,000 each, but we used one that cost about $750 each.
的胸部。是的，我们都吓坏了。是的，我们吓坏了，因为他接着割下了假人的脸，戴在了自己的脸上。就像《沉默的羔羊》一样。是的。我们收到了一些关于此的粉丝来信。人们想知道这一集里用了多少个心肺复苏假人。嗯。好吧，我问了兰迪。我很确定。雷恩确实切开了它，因为我们看着他做的。兰迪说我们总共用了三个心肺复苏人体模型。现在，等一下。等一下，大卫·华莱士会说它们每个价值3500美元，但兰迪说那有点夸张了。他说有一些高端假人带有非常复杂的功能，比如可活动的头部和心跳模拟器。那些在当时每个大约1000美元，但我们用的那个每个大约750美元。
Okay.
But listen, Dwight is in trouble again.
He has to go back to corporate, and he has to discuss his mutilation of the CPR dummy.
I really can't believe the guy is still employed.
I know.
Now he has this huge task where he has to go make this very public apology to his coworkers,
and they have to sign that they received his apology.
Yes, that's going to be now Dwight's task.
好的。但是听着，德怀特又惹麻烦了。他必须回到公司总部，讨论他损毁心肺复苏假人的行为。我真的不敢相信这家伙还在受雇。我知道。现在他有一个艰巨的任务，他必须向同事们公开道歉，而且他们必须签字确认收到了他的道歉。是的，那现在将是德怀特的任务。
Meanwhile, we've got this very interesting, somewhat odd.
other storyline that's going to come up.
It really seems like it comes out of nowhere.
It's in the break room.
Andy, I guess, is really good at pirating movies.
So you can see them before they come out.
And Jim and Pam are going to watch this movie with Andy on his laptop.
Yes.
与此同时，我们还有另一个非常有趣、有点奇怪的故事情节。它看起来真的是凭空出现的。是在休息室里。我想安迪真的很擅长盗版电影。所以你可以在电影上映前看到它们。吉姆和帕姆要和安迪在他的笔记本电脑上看这部电影。是的。
We got a lot of fan mail about this pirated movie scene.
Hannah E. Abby S. and Bet S said,
I am absolutely obsessed with the strange mini-movie Andy watches with Jack
Black and several other big names, how did this subplot come about?
Does it rhyme with Schmoooper Bowl?
It does.
Remember when I said there was that extra scrutiny?
我们收到了很多关于这个盗版电影场景的粉丝来信。汉娜·E、艾比·S和贝特·S说：我完全沉迷于安迪观看的那部有杰克·布莱克和几位大牌明星出演的奇怪小电影，这个副线情节是怎么来的？它是不是和“超级碗”（Super Bowl）押韵？确实是。确实是。还记得我说过有额外的审查吗？
Well, one of the things that the network was very insistent about was that this episode
have big name guest stars.
So they could flash it about.
Yeah.
Jack Black.
Jessica Alba.
Yes.
There was a lot of comparison to when other shows had run after the Super Bowl,
好吧，电视网非常坚持的一点是，这一集必须有大牌客串明星。这样他们就可以拿出来炫耀。是的。杰克·布莱克。杰西卡·阿尔芭。是的。人们经常拿它与其他在超级碗之后播出的节目进行比较，
like friends who had featured big guest stars.
But Greg and the rest of our writers were very against this.
Especially against it was Allison Jones, our casting director.
They all felt that to have like a big-name guest star walk into the office pretending to play a character at a small paper company would just totally shatter the reality of the documentary premise of our show.
We would get all these new eyes on the episode maybe, but the,
conceit of our show is that it's a documentary. That's right. You can't have Jack Black come in and
pretend to be a salesman. Exactly. But you can years later have James Spader play Robert California.
And have Idris Elva coming in and all these other people. And Timothy Oliphant. And Kathy Bates.
比如《老友记》，它就请过大牌客串明星。但格雷格和我们的其他编剧非常反对这一点。我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）尤其反对。他们都觉得，让一个大牌客串明星走进办公室，假装在一家小型造纸公司扮演角色，会彻底破坏我们节目纪录片前提的真实性。我们可能会吸引所有这些新目光来看这一集，但我们节目的核心理念是它是一部纪录片。没错。你不能让杰克·布莱克进来假装当推销员。没错。但几年后你可以让詹姆斯·斯派德扮演罗伯特·加利福尼亚。还有伊德里斯·艾尔巴进来，以及所有其他人。还有蒂莫西·奥利芬特。还有凯西·贝茨。
Okay. But for now, for now, our integrity is intact. Okay. And Greg came up with this idea,
this fix that would not infect the reality of the show.
And that was where the idea for Pam, Jim, and Andy to watch this pirated movie.
And I guess Terry Weinberg, who was one of our original executive producers,
was now working as the executive vice president of NBC Entertainment.
And Greg said that she was really instrumental in fighting like the kind of top brass at NBC to agree to this fix.
they did. Jack Black was the first person to commit. He was all in. He loved our show.
Cloris Leachman.
好吧。但目前为止，我们的完整性保持不变。好的。格雷格想出了这个主意，这个不会破坏节目真实性的补救措施。那就是帕姆、吉姆和安迪观看这部盗版电影的想法。我想泰瑞·温伯格（Terry Weinberg），我们最初的执行制片人之一，当时正在担任NBC娱乐公司的执行副总裁。格雷格说，她在对抗NBC高层以同意这个补救措施方面真的起到了关键作用。他们做到了。杰克·布莱克是第一个承诺的人。他全力以赴。他喜欢我们的节目。克萝丽丝·利奇曼（Cloris Leachman）。
Amazing, by the way. Amazing.
She heard a pitch on what the story would be, and she was like, yes, I am in. And then finally, we got Jessica Alba.
So the movie is called Mrs. Albert Hannity, and Jack Black is playing Sam.
Clarice Leachman is playing Lily, aka Nana, and Jessica Alba plays Sophie.
It's sort of a romantic love triangle story.
Yeah, Jack Black is dating or engaged to Jessica Alba's character, and she's introducing him to her grandmother.
And there's an instant connection.
I mean, they go to shake hands and music starts playing.
顺便说一句，太棒了。太棒了。她听了关于故事内容的推介，她说：好的，我加入。最后，我们请到了杰西卡·阿尔芭。所以这部电影叫《阿尔伯特·汉尼提夫人》（Mrs. Albert Hannity），杰克·布莱克扮演萨姆。克萝丽丝·利奇曼扮演莉莉，也就是娜娜，杰西卡·阿尔芭扮演索菲。这是一个浪漫的三角恋故事。是的，杰克·布莱克正在和杰西卡·阿尔芭的角色约会或订婚，她正把他介绍给她的祖母。他们之间有一种瞬间的联系。我的意思是，他们去握手，音乐就开始响起了。
Yeah, there's some electricity there.
Well, I want you to know there were some alt ideas for this parody movie, Jenna.
And I went back to the table read draft, not the shooting draft, just to see what it said in the table read.
In the table read draft, the movie was going to be called hang glider cop.
What?
And Jack Black would be a cop named Tanner that's kind of a rogue cop.
And he gets as punishment sent over to the hang gliding division.
Okay.
是的，那里有一些火花。好吧，我想让你知道，对于这部恶搞电影还有一些其他的想法，珍娜。我回去看了剧本朗读草稿，不是拍摄草稿，只是看看上面写了什么。在剧本朗读草稿中，这部电影原本要叫《滑翔伞警察》（Hang Glider Cop）。什么？杰克·布莱克会扮演一个叫坦纳的警察，他是一个有点叛逆的警察。作为惩罚，他被派到了滑翔伞部门。好的。
And now he's going to be a hang gliding cop.
A wacky comedy.
They're like a cop comedy.
Okay.
They didn't go with that one.
Probably getting a hang glider was too much of her project.
Gosh, I'd love to see that movie.
Hang glider cop.
现在他要成为一名滑翔伞警察了。一部古怪的喜剧。就像一部警察喜剧。好的。他们没有选那个。可能弄到一个滑翔伞太麻烦了。天哪，我真想看那部电影。《滑翔伞警察》。
Jack Black, are you listening?
Mm-hmm.
H.G. Division.
We got more fan questions about this.
Livy and G.
Norrit F.
And Maddie L. said,
Did we get to meet Jack Black,
杰克·布莱克，你在听吗？嗯哼。滑翔伞部门。我们还有更多关于这个的粉丝问题。利维和G·诺里特·F以及麦迪·L说：我们有机会见到杰克·布莱克、
Cloris Leachman, or Jessica Alba?
No.
We did not work the same day as they worked.
They filmed all of their stuff in one day at a private residence in West L.A.
The rest of us all had the day off.
They didn't even come to our base camp.
No, they were out of house.
I looked it up on the call sheet.
克萝丽丝·利奇曼或杰西卡·阿尔芭吗？没有。我们没有和他们同一天工作。他们把所有的戏份都在一天内拍完了，地点是在西洛杉矶的一处私人住宅。我们其余的人那天都休息。他们甚至没来我们的基地营。没有，他们是在外面拍的。我在通告单上查过了。
They started really early that day.
On the call sheet, it said breakfast would be ready for the crew at 4.42 a.m. in a nearby park.
Oof, they had to get everything in one day.
Yeah.
The actors all arrived really early.
they did their hair, makeup, and wardrobe fittings all in the morning. And then they were finally
allowed to go into the neighborhood where the house was located at 7 a.m. So they had vans that
took everyone from this park base camp over to the location. And that's where they filmed it.
那天他们开始得很早。通告单上说，剧组的早餐将在凌晨4点42分在附近的一个公园准备好。噢，他们必须在一天内完成所有拍摄。是的。演员们都到得很早。他们早上就完成了发型、化妆和服装试穿。然后他们终于在早上7点被允许进入房子所在的社区。所以他们有面包车把每个人从这个公园基地营送到拍摄地点。那就是他们拍摄的地方。
So we never met. So while they're watching Mrs. Albert Hannity, we start seeing Pam getting
all these text messages. And we learned this storyline that Pam's
parents are in a rough patch. Yes, and that Pam's dad is bunking with Jim and Pam.
It is really funny, though, that Jim and Pam were having these little sidebar relationship
conversations, and Andy thinks it's about the movie. Andy thinks you guys are just like geniuses
at relationships that you can just figure all this stuff out. Well, something else I should mention,
Angela, is that we were actually watching this movie. That's one of my questions for you.
I was like, asked Jenna, were they actually watching the movie on the movie?
所以我们从未见过面。所以当他们在看《阿尔伯特·汉尼提夫人》时，我们开始看到帕姆收到所有这些短信。我们了解到帕姆的父母正处于一段艰难时期。是的，帕姆的爸爸正和吉姆与帕姆住在一起。不过，吉姆和帕姆在进行这些小小的侧边关系对话，而安迪以为是在谈论电影，这真的很有趣。安迪以为你们在处理关系方面简直是天才，可以解决所有这些问题。好吧，安吉拉，我还要提一件事，我们当时确实在看这部电影。这是我问你的问题之一。我当时想，问问珍娜，他们是在电影里真的在看电影吗？
the laptop. So we were. How could you not react to Cloris coming out of the tub? You had to be
distracted on your phone. I was like, holy crap. So they had shot this a long time ago. If you look at
the call sheets for this episode, this bit of us in the conference room was not even on the schedule
for these nine days. We shot this another week later so that they could put together this
mini movie so that we could have some reactions. The first time they played them for us, we couldn't
speak. We were riveted. We were like, what are we watching? That was what I thought. I was like,
how can Jim and Pam, like, not just be falling out of their chairs right now? And Andy's like,
guys, they're making out. So what they did was they showed it to us. And then we watched a blank screen,
笔记本电脑上的。所以我们确实在看。你怎么可能不对克萝丽丝从浴缸里出来做出反应呢？你肯定会被手机分心。我当时想，天哪。所以他们很久以前就拍好了。如果你看这一集的通告单，我们在这个会议室里的片段甚至不在那九天的日程表上。我们是在一周后拍的，这样他们就可以把这部小电影剪辑出来，让我们做出反应。他们第一次给我们播放时，我们都说不出话来。我们被迷住了。我们当时想，我们在看什么？我当时就是这么想的。我当时想，吉姆和帕姆怎么可能现在不从椅子上掉下来？安迪说：伙计们，他们在亲热。所以他们做的是，他们把它放给我们看。然后我们看着一个空白屏幕，
but we knew what we were supposed to be reacting to.
You knew the beats of it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then they inserted it into the screen.
You know, if you notice, it's all over the shoulder.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was very curious about that.
但我们知道我们应该对什么做出反应。你知道它的节奏。是的。是的。然后他们把它插入到屏幕里。你知道，如果你注意的话，那都是过肩镜头。是的，是的，是的。我对此非常好奇。
Yeah, it was bonkers.
Well, after all the texting with Pam's mom and dad, Pam says, Jim, can you talk to my dad?
You're so good.
Yeah, maybe he'll open up to you.
Yeah.
This is not going to go the way Pam planned.
But that's for next.
是的，这太疯狂了。好吧，在和帕姆的妈妈和爸爸发了所有短信后，帕姆说：吉姆，你能和我爸爸谈谈吗？你很擅长这个。是的，也许他会向你敞开心扉。是的。这不会像帕姆计划的那样发展。是的。但那是下周的事了。
week. Well, before we close out this episode, Michael has decided to do yoga in the conference room.
For relaxation. It did really make me laugh when he was like, um, if you have your legs open,
close him, no one needs to see that. Um, or whatever he said, cracked me up. It also really made me
laugh when Jim says to Pam, don't open your eyes. She says, why. Oh, God. I don't know if you
noticed Dwight and Angela are laying side by side. Oh. Yeah, that's because there was a deleted scene.
where Dwight whispers to her,
I will make love to you the way I used to
if you will sign my apology letter.
好吧，在结束这一集之前，迈克尔决定在会议室做瑜伽。为了放松。当他说“如果你张开腿，把它们合上，没人需要看那个”或者无论他说了什么时，真的让我大笑，让我笑得不行。当吉姆对帕姆说“别睁开眼睛”时，也真的让我大笑。她说：为什么。噢，天哪。我不知道你有没有注意到德怀特和安吉拉并排躺着。噢。是的，那是因为有一个被删减的场景，德怀特对她耳语：如果你愿意签我的道歉信，我会像以前那样和你亲热。
And she's like, no.
Wow.
Well, during all of this,
Stanley has a little heart monitor on
and it beeps whenever he gets stressed.
Turns out every time Michael gets close to him,
it starts beeping.
And then when Michael walks away, it stops.
她说：不。哇。好吧，在这一切过程中，斯坦利戴着一个小型心脏监测器，每当他感到压力时它就会发出哔哔声。结果每次迈克尔靠近他，它就开始发出哔哔声。然后当迈克尔走开时，它就停了。
So Michael has this very funny talking head
where he says,
it turns out that Dwight wasn't the killer after all.
the killer was Michael, and he says, quote, you never suspect you're the killer. It's a great twist.
Great twist. Oh, my gosh, you guys, that was stress relief part one. I know. We did it. We did it.
Next week is part two. Boom. Roasted. That's next week. Thank you to everyone who contributed to this
episode. Thank you, Oscar, Randall, Rain and Brian for sending in your audio clips. Guys, Rain and Brian both have
podcasts. They are great. Rain is the host of metaphysical milkshake and Brian is the host of the
所以迈克尔有一个非常有趣的独白，他说：事实证明德怀特根本不是杀手，杀手是迈克尔，他说：引用一下，“你永远不会怀疑自己是杀手。”这是一个很棒的反转。很棒的反转。噢，天哪，伙计们，这就是《压力缓解》第一部分。我知道。我们做到了。我们做到了。下周是第二部分。砰。烤焦了。那是下周的事。感谢所有为这一集做出贡献的人。感谢奥斯卡、兰德尔、雷恩和布莱恩发来音频片段。伙计们，雷恩和布莱恩都有播客。他们很棒。雷恩是《Metaphysical Milkshake》的主持人，布莱恩是《Office Deep Dive》的主持人。
office deep dive. Yes. And also a huge thank you to Randy Cordray, Greg Daniels, Jeff Blitz,
Jen Salada, Paul Lieberstein, Dean Holland, James Carey. Oh my gosh, Kate Flannery. We reached out to so many
people. We always say thank you, but it's because we mean it. Really? Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you guys so much. And thank you for listening. We'll be back next week with part
too. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was
initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is
produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second
drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive
是的。还要非常感谢兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）、格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）、杰夫·布里茨（Jeff Blitz）、珍·萨拉达（Jen Salada）、保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）、迪恩·霍兰德（Dean Holland）、詹姆斯·凯里（James Carey）。噢，天哪，凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）。我们联系了很多人。我们总是说谢谢，但那是因为我们是真心的。真的吗？是的。谢谢。非常感谢你们。也谢谢你们的收听。我们下周会带着第二部分回来。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《Office Ladies' Second Drink》。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《Office Ladies》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。我们的《Second Drinks》剧集由莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛（Sam Pfeiffer）。Odyssey的执行
producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is
Ruppertree by Creed Braddon.
Spotify, it's Jay Shetty.
Are you one of those media strategy people?
Scrolling through spreadsheets, searching for an audience that pays twice as much attention
to your ads than they do on social?
Let me introduce you to fans.
And they're here with me on Spotify.
制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Braddon的《Ruppertree》。Spotify，我是杰·谢蒂（Jay Shetty）。你是那些媒体策略人员之一吗？滚动浏览电子表格，寻找那些对你的广告关注度比在社交媒体上高两倍的受众？让我向你介绍粉丝。他们和我一起在Spotify上。
Trust me, I know fans.
They don't skip.
They stay for hours.
They don't move on.
They manifest.
They're not a demographic group.
They're fans.
Spotify advertising.
相信我，我了解粉丝。他们不会跳过。他们会停留数小时。他们不会离开。他们会显现。他们不是一个人口统计群体。他们是粉丝。Spotify广告。
You're among fans.
Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
你就在粉丝之中。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森（Kelly Clarkson），代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想知道“如果……会怎样”？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。有了Wayfair，就没有“如果会怎样”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。
Visit Wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.
访问Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。